And tremendous. It's tremendous.
He has a a Hector Lombard sprawl,
you know Hector Lumbar? Yeah. Slams a
motherfucker down when he sprawls on you.
Hector Lombard has that.
We live, we live right now.
Hector Lombard has the
scariest Bra I've ever seen.
Like when he snapped down Tim Boetsch,
it was like bitch,
it wasn't just the wrong
date or had a crazy sprawl.
Actually he did,
but he was ready to crack
as soon as he got up.
Fatal was more wild in the transition
like wild punches and judo throws and
shit.
Fader was always wild and the transitions,
but I'm telling you Tim Boetsch and
Anthony Rumble Johnson at two the scariest
fucking sprawls I've ever seen.
Just how the zoom,
the presses like none of this is going on.
And who was he fighting next?
I don't know.
Little Mario. Mario Little
Nog Tam. Oh No, no, no, no,
no. Let me tell you some little,
Nog is a very good boxer. In fact,
he fought for the Brazilian national team.
He medalled,
he met for the Brazilian national team.
He's a bad motherfucker with his striking.
That's shut Rashad Evans Noun.
Like if you watch that Rashad Evans fight,
it wasn't the best fight for a shot.
He was a little off in that fight.
But one of the reasons why he
was a little office, cause no,
Garrett tagged him a couple of times
in that first round with clean shots.
He's a clean boxers. It's real
crisp technique and nothing flashy,
but he knows what the fuck he's doing
and he'll let you up zig when you
should've zagged. He'll, he'll crack
you. Him and his brother. Fuck yeah.
Whole all shit happens.
Someone's got a little
personal experiences share
somewhat ought to sit this kid.
He's better than his brother. Yeah, he's,
he's better than his brother's a boxer.
And he also submitted Dan Henderson.
He's one of the bolts submitted both
brothers and that crazy little noggin.
Big Nog. Both got him in an arm bar who
is so he's better. You think little knock?
It's actually better than his brother.
No, I think he's got better boxing,
but his brother was definitely more
successful, was the MMA fighter.
But it's only slightly better.
Like when you talk about like better look,
if the little nog in his brother boxed,
either one of them could
knock each other out.
It doesn't always play out that way.
Right?
Like Brendan and I were talking about
this before the podcast about no one
catches a lucky rear naked choke. Nope.
If two black belts are going at it,
the guy who taps the guy
is the better guy. Right?
But if two guys are slugging it out in
the gym, you fucking Shit can happen, man.
I seen guys,
I've seen guys who are really good get
lit up by a guy who's not that good in
the gym. It just get cracked with
a shot. You run into a hard jab,
something that takes your legs out,
but there are lucky shots and Jujitsu,
why live Jitsu is Dana that I was in like,
ah damn,
I accidentally called him in the
ankle luck. You know what I'm saying?
There's none of that ever after. Now I
accidentally got a rolling wheel hook.
You actually got to know what you're
doing and I can get lucky. You know,
you can throw any fat Duke
and throw a big right hand.
It hit you in the right spot.
What is it?
What is the one Jujitsu moves that it
has had the highest rate of success?
Let's let everybody know round one
of the John Linacre fight is
right about to take place.
If you listened to this podcast,
you never heard this.
This no philosophizing is what we're
doing is we're watching fights.
He has the fights are taking place.
We're talking shit.
Joey motherfucking Diaz's here.
Holla at your boy Joe Diaz.
What's happening and the job just
sitting in Brian Cowen, learn the fights.
The fight started.
You could probably,
it says four 43 right
there when I said that,
that's what it says as far as the time,
if you want to sync up because there's
a bit of a difference between the fights
and the, the uh, live
broadcast that we're doing.
There's like a 15 second delay,
something like that,
that look for me to make a lot of
comments in this fight. Companion guys,
shut down. John Lineker, that dude with
the red shorts. It's a fucking beast.
He's one of the hardest hitting
flyweights in the world.
GEICO racks but can't make the weight
keeps fucking up and missing is miss miss
this nice his weight cut twice. He would
have already had a shot at the title.
Look at how he hits this mother
fucker would a heart shot. He left,
hooks him to the upper rib cage.
Takes away worse.
Those are Ruth. It's Linacre
can fucking, I'm telling you,
I've seen a lot of dudes that
are in this weight class cracked.
He's totally different than all of them.
If, if every one 25 was like Linacre,
this would be a hugely exciting division.
This is mother fucker puts guys to sleep.
He hits hard.
He's got like weird power.
Like when he, when he hits you,
you see dudes like go like, whoa.
Nobody ever hit me like that before.
Bed At 1305120520 five
he's a flyweight man.
So he was supposed to be fighting with Dj.
Well that's why as a hard time making one
25 obviously you look at this, Ooh, Ooh,
Ooh, oh shit. Nice
takedown. Good strength.
Okay,
well, let me see. Is
from Brazil. Yeah. Att.
No,
pretty sure, right? Yeah. To set up a, uh,
he's doing a good job getting over that
leg. That left leg. Oh look, he's out.
He's out. He's out. Hmm. Oh, he left
that to be on top of him. You know what?
That's what's, that's what
sucks about the cage, right?
You can't skip your hips
back. Go shrimping. Yeah.
You're just stuck right there.
I think the cage benefits wrestlers
a lot more with their heavy hips.
The ground and pound. It's definitely
an advantage for a wrestler.
Is there a Jujitsu move that has had
the highest percentage of success in the
UFC? Rear naked choke. Yeah. Probably
a choke. Maybe a gay teen, Nick Eugene.
I think the most would be a rear naked.
Well, let's thank you. Sure had it.
I'm sure there's a stat
somewhere, right? Okay. What?
Submit on an Anaconda. Wait, hold
up. There's only been one that
Brendan, come on. Stop.
Stop you silly goose. Well,
other guys have hit anacondas
haven't done in the UFC.
Didn't. Um, I'm the heavyweight
division. Did, um, did Dave,
Phil Davis,
did he get a Doris Ah,
Gustafson Conda that's light
heavyweight it. Oh, that's right.
You said heavyweight. Sorry,
I thought you said in the UFC.
Oh, well he, but he did get
it. I know there's been,
there's been a bunch of Anacondas I
spend the heavyweight division a dope his
name right? Yeah. Anaconda choked
with, with the dope or name that uh,
an Anaconda killing somebody. Everybody
wants to be an Anaconda in Jujitsu.
This is the,
uh,
this is the fucking is the kangaroo
choke what it away from me,
but I want to add a condom on the fuckers.
Catch you do with the Anacostia.
Don't remember last time I saw besides
with it not with a kick butt with a punch,
somebody takes them down
with a liver shot. Oh,
it happens all the time
with hands with hands.
Well it happens with all kinds of things.
Kicks Gas but not,
I don't know about hands. I see
boxing, but not, it definitely happens.
That's when you know the
guys a high level striker,
if he's going to the bottom right,
especially in a high level fight.
If the hot high pressure fighting's go on
the body, he's a really hard to set up.
Right. You've seen Fabio
Miles Denato fight. Right.
You know he's not at the level
of the top guys and he got,
he got chewed up by music.
He just should not be we we called that
one just shouldn't have been fighting
heavy, just smaller. And Neo
chick is a sanction. That fight.
I agree with you 100% it was
a Brazilian sanctioning fight.
I don't think they probably
would have accepted it in Vegas.
Neil chick just had way too much for
him. Too much power, too much technique.
I Steve pay looked
fucking fantastic though.
He looked really crisp in that fight.
The Greeley. Yeah. Yeah. He looks,
he looked great. I'll, I'll,
I'll fuck frigging and drive
down to Poland from falls out.
If you want to hype it up.
How dare you.
I'm just saying it's a mismatch. Yes.
It wasn't well, and not only that,
he was a lot bigger too.
It looked like it was way bigger.
Maldinado was supposed
to be on another fight.
All should probably be find that 70 let's
be honest. Oh Shit. No you didn't. No.
For Real. No. He can make 70
it's got some extra weight.
He definitely has a few pounds.
He's a beast of a fight or some of the
best box and if not the best box in it.
Yeah,
well he's the best.
He's like one of the best at just and
shots and it's still coming forward.
Clover, clover. That was
tough to watch. Yeah, man.
But what about when he clipped Glover
with that left hand? It was kind of like,
oh shit. What's going on here? That
was pretty crazy. All right. One,
just want to see global versus DC.
That would have been a great fight.
Very interesting fight. Very DC
against anybody's very interesting.
Rear naked choke is number one.
That's what I thought. Yeah.
Rear naked choke is numero uno.
Number two. I'm going to say guilty
maybe. Armbar right? Nope.
Guilty. Let's see. Yeah,
because with wrestlers, a
lot of times people shoot in.
Yup. Guillotine number two.
Number two is killed and kind of crank
on someone's neck and choke them out.
Even if you're not, you know. Yeah. If you
don't know what you're doing. Yeah, yeah.
Like try and get pulling off budget doors.
If you don't know what you're doing,
try pulling off a Peruvian necktie.
Yeah, good fun. Yeah, but you right.
If you get someone's head
in there, you kind of headline
tangles. So for example,
chill Solon jail's not known for his
Jujitsu Gel. Sonin versus Shogun.
When he got him that Guillotine,
it was just kind of,
and he's arching back in like
straight Chels straight on.
But a lot of guys are arching back now.
A lot of guys are arching back if
they have a different angle, you know,
it used to be like,
would that army and teen that you,
everybody would have to say,
always say that you have to smother it.
But Eddie Bravo.
Now there's also a way to do it if
you're like sideways where you're arching
back, arch back sideways. He's like from
certain angles it's okay to arch back.
It's like that's the
complexity of Jujitsu. It's
just little tiny adjustments.
Like we were talking before the podcast
about Amal Easton taught me a variation
on the guillotine that was
really good for the defense,
which is to go over the top or the back.
But also there's just little variation
in the way you hold it made the bone of
the arm dig into the neck and just
that one little thing was like, ah,
fuck. But when you're looking
at it, it almost looks the same.
Like when someone shows it to you,
they're just showing you one little
tiny tweak. But that tiny tweak has it
with wrestling. It's interesting
because when the, when before the,
when the wall was up with the Soviet
Union and, and, and East Germany,
when they would meet,
they had their own technique and the
west have their own techniques and,
and they would watch tape on each other,
but they couldn't figure out really how,
what they were doing. Right.
Because it was so subtle when,
when the wall came down in the east,
all those eastern European started
coming over to the United States and
wrestling with those guys.
Wrestling changed dramatically like in
10 years because everybody's starting to
share their secrets because they couldn't
figure it out. Just watching tape.
It wasn't like you watched boxing.
It was so subtle.
The little differences like you're
talking about on like how one guy would
should a double leg or where he was
holding on the knee and stuff like that.
Made a huge Delta who didn't
give a shit about techniques.
You could show him whatever he wanted.
Whatever he did worked Shane color.
When they got a hold of your neck,
he was like,
how's that feeling like you're
literally about to break my neck.
I'm going to snap my neck.
He's way too busy too.
He's just too big of a human being.
I was at a malls place and he walked in
and he had a rash guard on like the skin
cut tight rash guards, short sleeve
rash guard, no fights scheduled, so z,
whatever the fuck he wants, including
Beck, Mexican supplements. Right. So he,
he lost him to the gym and he
didn't even look like a human.
He looked like Shrek.
Like if Shrek was a real person,
like it was so much bigger than everybody.
They're like, this is ridiculous.
Training partner for base my entire
career since I moved out to the Lord,
he and me, it would no one won't
work with. It was just me and Shane.
Shane took me under his wing and
paid for my private training.
But in exchange I was the only one
who would spar with him. Oh my God.
One day and I'll look and go put it hood,
his personal business out there.
But one day he was going through
some rough times at home.
Shamo is stressed out and he's 300
pounds and works kicking his ass and he's
very, very stressed out and
he's having girl problems.
So I show up to spar and this motherfucker
is there super like he's on the
couch, he's on the couch, right? I'm
like, what the hell are you doing dog?
He's like, oh, it was rough. Like
you know, she has a deep voice.
It was rough last night, slept. He
slept at the gym. I'm good though.
Literally almost in tears.
So I'm like, whatever man.
We spar and I catch him
with a decent right hand.
He has headgear on 300 pounds,
shaved silver back gorilla.
I hit him with a good
right hand and he goes,
fuck.
Ripped his head gear up,
shakes the cage tears or in his eyes,
he's just dealing with other stuff.
He's not doing well.
And I'm like, Oh fuck.
Oh it's me. It's me. Him and our coach,
Trevor Whitman was there
throwing Trevor and
Trevor goes, Shane, take a minute.
No, I'm good, I'm good. And I'm like,
what about me? Man? Don't
freaking out crying. Oh my God, that's
terrifying. He knocked out and saw Tommy.
He knocked out Gonzaga with a six
inch punch. It was like this far.
But when you're free,
when you're aspiring with him,
the head is not doing shit
really against those giant myth.
So that's why my foot work
got good because no, there's,
there's no what you got hit by
Shink carver and fist. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean if everything that he was
just, he just fit your, your heart.
Your heart is beating every day,
every everything.
Your heart's beating all the
time. Like, you're right,
you're not looking forward to sparring.
It's sucks, right. I was terrible.
I would sit in my car before and she'd be
like, God damn, I don't want to do this.
And then Shane would text me where he
at, Bro. Ah. I just parked, coming,
talking to my, what else when
it comes from Tony Rob talking,
I stopped talking and he leaves. I started
talking again. It was like Deebo dog.
He's just punk guy. He hit so
hard. He was so big too. Oh Man.
The first round again, Brock Lesnar, man,
that was the game changer when he did
that thing where he picked me up and
squeeze me and I started tapping
and he and I heard him whisper,
I'm only at 40% pro my arm.
I had he hit a nerve or something for
like a month later my arm and get these
weird numb smells when Shane would drink.
He's one of those guys who had hit ya.
I hate being hill. You're 300 pounds.
We're in downtown Denver for sure.
Don't hit me in front of people.
I would, my body be tore up. Hey,
he's all busted up from football.
Yeah, it's back like bonds, wrestling.
Cause by them I mean, yeah, he was
a middle linebacker at western.
She got a tryout with the Philadelphia
Eagles and then he wrestled, you know,
high, high caliber wrestler Man College,
High School, everything. Yeah, you,
Bonnie just can only take so much.
So soft tissue areas,
the breakdown areas inside the toilet.
Man, I miss that guy. Ooh. Do I miss him?
Best training partner I've ever had.
Good dude to be around.
It was one of the guys went when I can
afford to work with Trevor Whitman,
who was like this crazy, right.
W had world champions. Um,
Shane sought him out and was
like, hey, come with me. I'm
like, Brian, what do you,
what do you mean, give them a fucking
backroad for myth or I've got nothing.
You're right. I didn't
have much money. And uh,
Shane talked with them and then
the next day he was like, hey,
you're coming with me.
Shana. Have a ton of money.
Either he just put it all on his credit
card, paid for mine and his private.
So me and Shane workout at the
same time. Wow. That's pretty cool.
Very cool of them. What is it like working
with Whitman? You're like Whitman. Yeah.
Yeah.
Women's biggest thing man is he's just,
he's a super positive guy
and he's creative, you know?
And um, yeah, I mean listen,
when he did was with Shane and, and,
and with me was, was pretty cool.
He had two straight flat canvases.
Me and Shane were like,
rock 'em sock 'em robots, which is
why I stutter now. It's every round,
every round they would give
us the 32nd marker. We,
no matter what we're doing on the ground
wrestling, whatever, we'd both get up,
go to send an octagon, hit gloves and
sit there and punch each other in the,
I wish, I wish Trevor would be like,
Hey Brendan, listen. That's great.
Ron, do you a solid, don't
do that anymore, right?
Because you played football for your
whole life and then you free spark.
You sparred with Shane Carmen for
eight years. You definitely have.
You definitely have some brain tree.
I'll tell you what though.
Best literally best train partner
in the war. He get a brain trauma.
Look at this fucking thing.
You guys are missing a crazy fight.
Linacre is going off, man.
Jesus Christ guys are landing.
Oh, crazy man. Yeah, but Linacre is like,
it's just a difference. When he hits you,
it just sucks. This is why the injuries.
I talked to Joe Daddy, I worked with them.
You got a good body shot in there. Joe
Daddy. I said, do you have any injuries?
He goes, yeah, I got to crack
pelvis. Um, broke my pelvis,
broke three bones in my neck. I was
like, Jesus broke my pelvis. I said,
how'd you do that? He goes, I don't
know. A fight. I think I got kicked. Oh,
you don't know. Oh, okay.
Broke. Yeah, Bob Sapp. It's
ridiculous by the way. It's fine.
It's incredible.
Okay.
You know what's
incredible? I'm looking. I,
Lennox said he starts about three rows up.
Check out the people three rows and
beyond looking at fat dude, he always,
sure
you guys have no fucking
idea what Atlantic city is.
I've never been hell first bus white
trash in from all fucking ports.
It's 15 to get on the bus and to go
to Atlantic city. He is the clinker,
they give you $10 in quarters
when you get to Atlantic city.
So they basically give you $10 back.
Then they give you a book of
coupons for another 50 to eat.
We try to keep you there all day.
So if you go,
let's say at the eight
o'clock in the morning bus,
you can't leave till five
whether you're broke,
whether you wait all your coupons,
you cannot go back on the fuck
the,
they have a scam every fucking hour on
the hour from all points in New Jersey
and New York buses go down
to Atlantic city right now.
Half those people sitting there,
I've already lost that money and they
just killing time to the midnight bus and
somebody from the UFC just
happened to give him nice tickets.
They're sitting there,
they don't even know what the fuck
bookmaker,
who's going to win the fucking the Yankee
game because that's how they're going
to bounce back on Sunday and they could
go down to the shore and they look at
them. They're mummified.
It looks like fucking old.
And this is silver right there on his
face. That's Atlantic City for you.
Where's fucking Dana and this room
where they body got good body shot.
Where's Dana White?
He ain't nobody responding yet.
They haven't showed him the
fatigue or brothers fuck over.
They were in that room to hide.
Yeah. And the the the main
like, like Fox sports fight.
It comes out for that.
Like towards the end,
like when we have that
thing where we sit down,
we start breaking down the fights in
the man card. That's when he comes back.
He's guys are gonna Act Dag Oscar
that you can take it though, man.
He seemed to some hard shot
standing his ground, man.
You guys are sweating hombre.
Fucking Dana white comes in like
deliver on Goodfellas, shaking the hands
towards the end. Shaking
hands, boy that people,
people,
when is there ever been $1 billion
organization with a president like that?
I know he's, he's a character in a
movie. He doesn't even exist in a movie.
Go get his Twitter feed.
He goes back and forth with idiots.
Idiots talk shit talk
shit right back to him.
Makes Fun of their pictures and shit. He's
fucking funny. It's fucking funny man.
People get angry and he's like, I'm having
a good time. It's different for sure.
I stand never Tim Tebow. He walks
by, he goes, Tim Tebow, Timothy,
well thanks for coming out. And it just
keeps walking by. Just shouts at them.
It works. It works. You know groups,
the tiny man because the kid is tough as
shit. Oh school. Which is no joke man.
But he has eaten some bombs and
Linacre is just coming on a man.
I like this guy. Oh Shit.
Mixed up them kick sons.
How some guys can take these kids,
Huh? Well he was kicking earlier.
He landed some really good leg kicks.
He just turned it into.
How often is it slippery in there? Because
people say that the canvas is very,
I, I've never really had
an issue with the canvas.
The only time I've had an issue is when,
uh,
one of the fight monsters,
I was fighting the, uh,
when the logos get wet, they get slippery.
That's the only liquor cracked him.
Oh that's it. That's it.
We're into the third round.
Okay.
Dominating a fight for three rounds.
Actually I don't know if he was dominating
the second cause we were talking shit
dominating a fight in the third round
for sure and still [inaudible] as
[inaudible] ago. He's a beast dude.
I'm telling you. You kaos everybody.
He's a beast. That was a weight
problems. A away problem.
Well he needs to hire like
a dolce. Get on it. It lets,
lets say you can't afford dolce. Let's
say dolce. Whose Guns Street? Hollywood.
You can't afford them. Who Do you go
with? An MMA? It's a very good question.
There's a void to be filled. Oh Nice.
Left Hook. Look at that stumble. Whom?
Oh Dude Dude. Ouch. Knockers obese man.
Fuck an angle for me to get into
nutrition. That's it. Joey Diaz.
Let's do it.
Don't worry about that.
And I'm going to drive you somewhere
nice just to, come on. Let's go down.
Joey is Linacre okay.
Fucking good tech to no he throws wide
shots but he's got a lot of weight behind
them.
Super wide in that situation.
He's a beast man. You don't want to be
credit by that guy. But you know what?
I think Dj's too fast. Djs
too fast. Too smart too.
He's not going to stand in
front of you like that. No,
it's going to be a totally different,
it'd be interesting to
see if Linacre can adapt.
If you think about the chance
in every division there,
the guy with the best defense,
a lot, think about it.
Most of them name all the champs.
Most of them have the very
best defense in [inaudible].
His cane have really good defense.
I am.
Saul came really get
caught to the junior fight,
did junior fight that can happen
to anyone. And then those fights,
what he got dropped by, um, Chuck Congo,
Congo hit him perfectly at like
six fights. But think about it now.
Like Junior dos Santos really?
We're not hearing a peep out of striking
against cane. Yeah. But nothing,
the cane thing. He got
dropped by by um, uh,
Chuck Congo, Congo and just immediately
shoots in and gets a double.
It's cause that's what's natural to them.
That's gotten me in trouble.
Like Frank Mir and I were talking about
this when Frank Mir fought Nogueira, um,
he got blasted with a right hand blasted,
right.
He's on Queer street shaking and his,
his kind of Plan B,
just his body automatically does it.
It shoots in and that's when he shot
in and then caught broke his arm here.
That would come around. No,
Garrett could have finished them.
I thought no guera went to finish him
because Nogueira wanted to make a point
because frank was saying something
about no Gareth's Jujitsu.
So he's not worried about new
Garrett's Jujitsu, numeric,
no new Garrels Jujitsu's kind of base.
And it went for that good team. Yeah.
And she won the,
what I had heard was that he wanted to
submit Frank Mir because of their first
fight, like to sort of prove
a point, which is great,
but you would've had an extra whatever,
225 k in the bank if he just
kept punching him like this.
It was literally over and me and frank
were talking about in the back and I was
like, that right hand man, I
go in the locker room. You're
that fucking right hand.
He goes, Bro, I got caught the
exact same way you did. He goes,
but you're a natural instinct
was sit there and swing.
My body just took over
and I fucking went in man.
Meanwhile that was like the
most devastating turnaround
and then sound or that
submission.
Frank Mir Noguera he broke his arm
in how at the top like you can see,
oh yeah. Brazilian cats are
especially no gears, no nuts happened.
Frank Mir I think greatest heavyweight
submission artists of all time,
it's hard to argue is definitely the
best bone breaker it take to, to,
to actually come back from an injury.
Like that depends if you
ever come back from it.
I mean Tim Silvia arguably
was never the same.
Tim Silvia arguably was never the same.
I mean he was always a big
right hand punch her, but
he had a real good left too.
And he had no real problems with that arm.
Like he thanked Herb Dean for saving his
career by stopping that fight cause he
was trying to keep going and try and
keep swinging cause just he's a champ,
you know? Yeah. But who knows. Only he
knows only he knows how the effectors are.
Only Nogueira knows how
that arm affected him. Beat.
He had affected him for a long time.
He had to postpone a fight because his
recovery was not going as quickly as he
thought it was. A lot of guys are
crazy. The loudest I've ever chaired.
His win for someone who's not a
friend or a teammate is for Frank Mir.
When he flopped Brock Lesnar,
I wanted to beat Brock so bad because
I didn't want Brock to come from WWE
playing grab ass,
make all this money and just
stroll over and just destroy catch.
Which is what he was cheering for him
when he got him in that ankle lock.
Oh yeah. And he got beat by Jitsu.
Yeah. Favorite fight of all time.
But it was the one a bat,
the one of the worst taps ever because
the referee was just not on it, man.
He just didn't get on a quick
enough fucking Mazza Gotti.
You're a heavyweight and see Mazda. Yeah,
for sure. But you're like damn son this.
He's a good to have my head.
On a swivel on that mental lapses that
you can't have and when you got a guy
like Frank Mir yanking on
your fucking knee bone, yeah,
you better watch your p's and q's.
Gotta Break Pencil Yard. Yeah. God,
that'll just take out
your destroy your did.
He broke Tim Silvia's arm in a weird way.
Like he had the elbow like he was
real low down on the, on the arm bar.
Frank Mir frustrates me. Frustrates me.
What am I? Literally we talked about it.
One of my favorite guys,
Bro.
If I'm Frank Mir and I got those nasty
leg locks and all this shit and I'm
fighting Daniel Cormay, Josh
Barnett, whoever you though,
Josh is a beast on the ground.
I'm jumping to half guard son.
I'm going for your fucking legs because
most guys aren't no matter. Let's listen.
If you're fighting Frank Mir and you're
not a leg lock specialist and you're
like, God, I got three months to get
ready for it. That do just do what you do.
Forget about the fucking leg locks
cause he gets a hold of you in trouble.
You're just in three months.
You want to know basic to teach.
You don't think everyone
he trains with knows basic.
But if you're Frank Mir is train partner,
you're like yeah I know some shit on the
ground with my legs because I trained
with frank and he's still, he's
adapting that and catching them. Right.
So then you go into the fight and you
get caught in this complex ankle lock and
your defendant with the first
basic defense cause you're not,
it isn't that assuming that you
really deeply caught though.
I mean there's a lot of the defense's
catching it before it ever gets back for
sure. I mean if you've got to know it
gets caught. I mean if he catches it,
you're right. It's a good attempt by,
but you should know like basic defense.
Like he got it done that fast
before you took the truck.
If you got three weeks you can improve
your basic defense quite a bit.
Oh there's Trevor Whitman.
So what you're telling me all the fucker
you're fighting Ronda than too much.
I know.
I know from being a moron that
if she touches my fucking wrist,
you got to know what she's doing,
what she's doing.
So you could maybe like look at me.
She'd take me,
she held it off till the third round.
You know the only reason why she held
it off cause she knew what was going on
and me shirt submission artist herself,
Michelle hired uh,
a teammate of Rhonda is who did,
Jude owns known for arm bars.
Rhonda was very hurt by it.
Yeah.
Hired someone who was on the team with
Ryan or they were in the same circle to
brought her in and she was like, yeah,
if you pay me I'll help you out his side.
Defend Rondo's Armbar wow. Wait a piss
up. Wait a fricking poke. The bear.
Rondo's like what? Fuck Your
Armand poked the bear. Yeah. That.
Enjoy that.
That is the last bit you want your
weight class when she hit Alexis Davis,
is that right hand knee to the body and
then who hip toss full weight on her
right. Boob lands into side
Mount Bang, Bang, Bang, Bang,
Bang. I love it. That's how, that's
how you know the rest of the bitches.
They're like, who else wants some? No,
no, you're good. No one wants. Well,
cats and Gannon said she wants a fighter,
but yeah, like like two weeks later.
I know. I'll find her not, I
have this fight though. What?
We'll figure it out. Yeah.
No Shit. Heavyweights,
heavyweights, Sonia.
It's not got you look on Twitter it the
number of fucking 45th rank guy in the
world's calling canine girls. They're
like, no, we're cool. You got this girl
all the fucking movie premiere,
right? They buy all their tickets.
What's with scary about her is she's
getting better and she's way better than
everybody else and she's getting better.
Every time she fights, he's better.
The fucking Sarah McMahon fight
boom knee to the body takes her out.
Ever seen that? Just crushed our
crusher with the need of the body.
This fight catches it with a right hand
and then perfectly placed in need of the
body and then a hip toss about as good
as you've ever seen in the UFC was broke.
Damages neck. Yeah. Everyone's
like, oh my God. Rhonda said,
I guess that she was out like when she
was thrown and she could tell that she
was limping.
She so she had probably got knocked out
by either the punch or the need of the
body sometimes makes you just go limp.
Because if I am correct,
I think she hit her with a left knee,
which is like a left hook on that
side of your body. However liver shot.
So she probably brutalize her.
Shuts your whole system.
Pickpockets, Puerto Rican, pickpockets,
looking at shit. Fucking
town. Are you fucking crazy?
Atlantic city.
The best fight and that fucking caught
is the one after the fucking on the
boardwalk. Fuck. Hey,
what do you think about this possibility
that Gina might sign or that Holly Holm
is gonna find her next? Uh, Holly
Holmes not going to find an neck.
Holly Holm said she wants
a couple more fights for,
she takes on Rhonda and Rhonda is
the Mike Tyson effect man who won.
Who else wants some of Rhonda, right?
Who else wants some a depot. It was like,
now we're good now bitches.
Cause before bits were like,
well I'll be the main event championship
fight on. We have all these cameras.
Not if he lasts eight seconds,
bitch. No one remembers you.
You gotta hang in there like
Liz Carmouche. We're out
with her in Vegas. Yeah,
it all. Anyone came up and talked her
about was her fight with Ronda? Yup. Ah,
you almost had her those
course. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
Well that's always what happens too
when someone is like this super dominant
person.
It's like people are waiting to see them
lose their waiting to see him get beat.
That's the number one reason why
people go to a Floyd Mayweather fight.
Just want to see him lose. Yeah.
If there was like a percentage,
like how many people are
here to see Floyd loses?
It's probably like 40% we all were hate
her in the crowd here and they all have
his team money.
Mayweather. I saw him once.
I saw him once after that fucking laugh.
16 but you won't see Joe Silva for months.
They got him with a briefcase in the
neighborhoods. They got him in Africa,
they got him in England.
What are you talking about?
The book or after fucking
Rhonda. Oh, beat the hell out.
And they just took them on
Monday's meeting, Joe Silver.
You're gonna load long fucking trip long.
You've got to go find some fucking body
to fight this chick this time you got to
go somewhere deep in the
jungle somewhere deep.
But what's interesting about
the Gina Carano things,
if the Gina Carano does fight
that she's gonna fight her first.
That's how it should be,
because that's what Gina Crown has one
fight to make her career relevant and
acting yet.
So she gets one fight against Ronda.
They publicize the shit out of it.
Rhonda likes Gina. She's a fan,
so she's not going to,
you know,
she's not going to rip her
head off if someone said,
Yo girl getting most of the
girls out there said, hey,
you got to fight Ronda Rousey. Just
let her arm bar. You get like a male.
It's all good.
She's not going to hurt your face.
She's going to body slam you on your
back and then she's gonna break your arm.
But you just gotta tap early. You can get
a nice meal. You know what I'm saying?
Every chicken heads like Yo,
hell yeah.
Chicken and walking out with their
black belt around their neck.
Did Gina is going to have a
hard time making 40 35 no, no.
She's going to hire a professional.
She was never known for work ethic.
You know what I'm saying?
So now I think she's going to give it,
it lit a legit go.
She does fight.
Ronda striking is pretty
legit, isn't it? Yeah.
It doesn't matter what the fuck she does.
I'm telling you it's
going to last one round.
Hofi lasts longer than the
last grow at 16 seconds.
So we at least get to see some of it.
You know what I'm saying?
But just get in shape and
show up. Tap Out, get your
jacket. Go have some fun here.
Just saying call big brown. You know
what I'm saying? I'm a good time.
So you're, you're giving her, you're
giving her just the first round.
You're saying that that's how dominant.
You kidding me. No time in a fight.
No.
They should be like [inaudible] versus
the guy who made his burrito come check
it out and it's,
it's like it's not going to last
because she's been out so long or just,
it's just a different level.
It's a different level.
What are we talking about
that Alexis Davis is a beat.
Let me say what about this?
What about juice to the tits Cyborg
when she was out of bed to the tits?
Uh,
I think Cyborg when she was at her
best. That's a tough fight. Yeah,
it's a tough fight. Cyber could hit
really hard. Cyborg making really Cyborg.
Cyborg, making one 35 with strict
testing, going to get eight the fuck up.
That's one 35. Which trick testing
is a little bit problematic.
I'd like to go back in time to the pride.
She was one 75 and she would whoop my ass.
What are we talking about?
Tina? She's, she was
telling me she was terrible.
The picture up there was a picture of
her from behind and her husband Cyborg,
you know,
and her back is roughly as wide as it was.
She slimmed down considerably.
I've got a lot of respect for her man.
She told me she fought that a kickboxing
Muay Thai chick who nobody wanted to
fight for three years and Cyborg fodder
I think in like her fourth fight or
something like that.
And even though she doesn't look like
physically the same when she was like
super intimidating, scary. When
she fucking with Ron and Wanda,
she looked like Vandelay with some
corn rows. Yes. Yes. She doesn't.
She looks much more womanly now, but
she's still a beast. She's still,
she lost interest. Yes, she did.
Super. But I'll tell you what, man,
she got cracked in the first round. She
got front, kicked in the face and dropped.
She got up and she came
after this chick man.
The chick was still going after her.
I mean it was a wild ass fight scene
and the woman she fought is so legit.
She hasn't been able to secure a fight in
three fucking years. Wow. She's really,
I would still rather watch Misa,
Miesha Tate fight even.
She can lose six in a row. Cool. Yeah,
she's attractive. Wow. Rhonda Rabbit. Yep.
Brennan. I know what I'm saying. Ronald.
Gina Carano verse Ron would be the
biggest women's fight ever. Why?
Because they're both hot. It's what
we all want. That little thing.
Turn the lights on them. Get sweaty.
When are we taught that? Listen,
I am a hardcore fan. I will watch cyborg
fight. Anybody. Every time she's fighting,
I'm watching.
I watched her invicta fights.
I'm going to watch and she fights at
one 35. I think she's a bad ass fighter.
I think she really,
she's a beast man.
I'm just saying if you gave me my pick,
I would pick these other girls.
I actually don't agree with you on that.
I like watching the most skilled fighter.
UFC knows they have a problem.
We got to come up with no money.
Well I think if there's anybody that's
got a chance, it might be sidebar. Listen,
they've got to come up with
next for fucking girls.
If cyborg can comfortably at the
same time. That's two years. Uh,
it was funny cause yeah, she'll
take on the top pitcher. If I'm,
if I'm fucking Tom Rhonda as advisor.
I'm saying you fight two more times and
we're out gas. Where are we going to?
We're going to wait around until they
find some monster working out and fricking
Bruce has got to be some flyer up gold
medalists right now that are sitting
around some judo people that
are sitting around right now.
They're seeing the money she's making,
which has been able to do for sure.
It's gotta be some wrestlers.
They're all coming up and say shit
about them putting together a career and
getting to a position where
they can actually challenge
her and not just jumping
right into the lion's mouth.
Cause anybody, she may be, Gosh,
she's going to be out before that happens.
I think I know that. I don't think so,
dude.
I think she likes beaten bitches ass.
I think it's just going to stick around.
I think she's going to stick around.
She enjoys it, man.
She's too good to stop.
Was saying stop and next week maybe
three or four, maybe two more.
You got to realize she's been doing
judo since she's a kid. Her body's not,
you know what I'm saying? Yeah. Well,
she's got a little bit of knee surgery
she's about to do right now. She'll be,
she did it. Uh, I think so. They cleaned
it up. Scope the knee. But listen man,
she's too good to stop.
She's revolutionary. Good.
She's redefining combat sports for women.
She stopped right now
it's just a straight man,
but she's still getting get
better, man. She gets paid.
She's still gonna get paid a lot
of money on. She's so gigantic.
I don't think she's going to stop.
I think you're crazy. I think
she's going to stop. You
think should should uh, I
think after three fights. Wow.
Would you stick around and wait for what?
Till they find a monster to beat you.
But is that what she's doing? She
stopped with her kids and she stuttering.
How long are you going to
wait? I need more money. Oh,
in her movie careers. Boom.
And she's also been pretty vocal about
the fact that she is going to retire
sooner than later. How should
been at least ted? So on
my podcast, it's, you know,
she, she's been pretty, you mean,
you mean our pocket? Oh, no.
Even mind the went on when I did it on
that on Brian Calco. I didn't know Brian.
Brian thoughts,
mother fucker call this show man
for awhile I had to talk to him.
Joseph just call it Brian Calley.
Brian Cowen show.
I shouldn't even named my
show the Joe Rogan experience,
but I just did it cause I'm a Jimi
Hendrix fan cause you see the Jimi Hendrix
mugshots behind me. I just named
it that just for, you know,
it was a goof. You know we, we
had a laptop with snowflakes.
Yup. John proctor. Oh Massachusetts boy.
Those dudes like the fight.
Which one?
Which would proctor the Salus.
Ooh,
that's thrown at pencil.
Quincy mass in the house.
I'll make sure you make sure your
tweet for me. I'm going to be at the,
you know West Palm. Him. You
don't do it for yourself. Come on.
Tom's is finding that tells me a tweet
for him and I check his page and he
hasn't tweeted. I know. It was like, hey
dude, you can't do that. So mad at me.
He's like, Hey asshole. He
asked me to you and he has,
he done it and it's at my traps like
I pray, I'm like, oh, it didn't go.
So like for instance,
August 1st I'm going to be at the ace
theater in downtown La with Joey and
Dunkin and we've been tweeting that
shit for weeks. I've been tweeting,
I've been doing Instagram and tweeting.
You've been doing some of those Instagram
videos, but you are off on Twitter. Hey,
by the way, for real. It's
not so bad. I was like,
you need to tweak this out please.
So you open the life map
Brendan or Hashtag phone
the kid what we use.
He just puts Brandon's really funny,
this one. And then put a link.
Everyone's like, what the fuck
I gotta I gotta learn how to do.
I'm really Ketel one. Learning. Sure.
Learn. Pay attention a little. Listen.
Do you have a fucking iPad for a phone?
I know
you didn't give us any love
for the picture that we
Instagram where I'm jumping
in the air. I did you get a text back?
No, I didn't. I did send it to you.
I send you a text back you big time.
Yeah,
I think I text back Hahahahahaha
but I was in Hawaii.
Somebody was like flying squirrels. We
got all kinds of things. Some funny,
it's not rape if you swim surprise. I was
impressed with what you write. I didn't,
I didn't. You thought, Huh?
That works for me though. Yeah.
Sexy man.
I want to tell you one time me,
I want to thank America for all
the comments about my shorts. Yeah,
you were jumping pretty high. Our
friend who took that picture literally,
I was like, hey, take this picture.
Just fools about the blows up asshole
out jumping on the beach. So they, they,
he jumped and she got it in one snap and
I was like, let me see that. Hi Mike.
Brian, get over here.
I was like, oh my God,
perfect shot sun reflecting
off my pitch and chest.
Did you run in jump or did
you like sort of, but I felt,
I remember about 40 yards. I remember
I fell. I was like, I feel I go, I go,
I'm going to jump high cause I used to do
all his demonstrations and Tae Kwon Do.
I go, I want to jump really high
demonstration. I took ballet,
I took ballet for two years in theater
school and I did you even admit that I
will and I, why can't it just be a
cool picture? Nope. Gotta keep going.
Gotta push it and a Leotard for two
years and I could jump a leotard.
Yes, I did. You're kicking. Uh,
well I had been doing taekwondo
so actually could do all the,
I could do all the jumps and stuff. Like,
you know, I can, if you can do a jumping,
we'll kick. You can do a tour. Shah Tay in
the air. What's that? You guys Google it.
You Tay? Yeah, it's called [inaudible].
How many times have you had a girl say
yes because you could say towards j and
she's like,
let's just give it to me.
I had sex with all the girls in my ballet
class. Don't have to sell all of them.
Oh my God. I was a young man. They
probably thought you were confused.
They were trying to fuck
you back to straight around.
You have to wear a dance belt,
which is essentially a thong
and a cloth around your,
what did your dad say when he
said you want to do ballet?
My Dad to the ballet fan is he?
My Dad signed me up for it.
He's a ballet and opera fan. Him. If Mike
had told me that like damn little dude,
I was so good. It was a very, I was, I'm
more I, I should've been a ballet dancer.
I'm bill for it. Are you
joking? I'm being dead serious.
I was a natural get the fuck. I was a
natural. I could do four pirouettes.
I'm not kidding.
How weird is this Jack Daniels
commercial for fucking Frank Sinatra?
What a Frank Sinatra was alive.
He'd be like, hey Yo, yo, yo,
what the fuck are you doing? What are
we doing in my songs and my pitch jog.
We'll fucking sold me here.
Who Sold?
No one's making bank though
for Sinatra was alive.
Him doing a Jack Daniels
commercial fuck snap on its face.
I think Elvis made more when he was
dead after was dead from all the
songs than they did when he was alive.
And Christopher Walken wrote a
one man show about it, called him.
That was Joey's theory on a
Michael Jackson. Yup, he is.
What's up Michael Jackson
is making more money now.
Jackson was dead when he was
alive. He was broke. Yup.
And the day he died, his stock look it
up. Yup. He's made more this year than,
Whoa, look at that logo. No. Oh my
God. Oh No. Ain't that a bitch though.
Let's sucks, man. Making all
that money after you're gone.
I guess it helps the family up.
What's going on with that thing?
Is that a hematoma and that's just
what happened to my cheek, bro.
Everyone's like, oh, you broke your
jaw. Nah Man, let's he headbutted me.
My cheek swelled up like
a bumblebee stone. Yeah.
I thought you had a broken jaw for sure.
No Sir. Flourishing now back to training.
Powerful. Powerful. Brendan washing
pro Joe proctors face looks crazy.
It's got a mouse live in near his ear.
Dude.
Is that moves towards is either going
to stop trouble cause he really,
it's one of those, one of those
are New Guinea. Super Damon's.
It is cause in a burst in your eyeball.
Oh Shit.
He's already hitting that same spot.
I guarantee he made a couple of
fucking cop 100 million Mj last year,
2013 earnings from Michael Jackson.
Garen Filthy Rich,
Huh?
And when he died it was all a scam.
It was all a dream.
He owned like the fucking man.
You could see something coming.
Remember they started putting the
Beales back on iTunes. It was a big,
I was scanning. He owned the
fucking things. He was in debt.
They were losing his shit.
Paul Mccartney did the super bowl.
All of a sudden he came back at 67 like
he needs any fucking money that he made
$125 billion last year.
Made over 700 in the last five.
Oh my. He's got 700 million.
I'll trade spots with him. Right?
Why wait?
His kids wouldn't mind having his money.
He's dead.
His kids are living in like
fucking doctors show Jacksons
live in like a dock to
doc the oh that's so funny.
They were all living like fucking doctors.
Unbelievable.
125 million.
It's weird that you could sell
someone shit after they're dead.
It almost kind of seems
like when you're dead,
all your artwork should be free today.
Interesting looking referee.
He's got those corn rows. I'm trying
to figure him out so it looks like,
you know what? He looks like the
female fighter in million dollar baby.
What would you do, Brian? If you, uh,
if you were going to die and you
had like a long career behind you,
your kids are all full grown,
everybody's healthy and you,
you had this idea that when you
died you're going to be like a more,
more valuable than you are alive.
Like what? Like Michael Foundation,
I'd set up a charity, a foundation. Um,
but just but a charity that training
like a school that trained like I go like
to set up schools and like the
way Andre Agassi did it in the
inner cities and stuff.
Cause you remember the shit that was
going down with Michael Jackson's kids?
Joey? No. Yeah, there was some
shit where Michael Jackson's kids,
his mom was missing.
Remember his mom was missing
and the kids,
they are having a hard time
because everybody knows
that they're like in line to
inherit that money.
Imagine you have that whole 700
million just giant group of people,
whoever it has a vested interest in
that just hovering over that honey pot.
That is the Michael Jackson
estate. Yeah, but seeing his kids,
his kids are going to get massive dinero
like forget about a career like those
kids like oh damn proctor cracked
and what that left proctor, my wind.
This even with that crazy Hema
tomia bro. So here's, here's,
here's what we need to learn from this.
As you need to fake your death,
start making some bank. That's where
the money's at. But you can't enjoy it.
It isn't. You have to have to be
questioned though. Like what would you do?
How would you say you heard him
again? Oh, he's messed up, man.
He's really fucked clothes.
That's it.
Let's Damn Joe proctor with a
mouse grown out of his head.
Let's do something else with
Massachusetts son make. Last year,
Jamie would have to pack, make
5 million, 3 million, 3 million,
$5 over the course of his death.
He's probably made a shitload.
Now can they stick out?
This is gonna sound weird,
but can they stick a needle
in that drain that yeah,
they're going to have to
drain it for definitely. Yeah.
When you don't dream blood like that and
it pulls up and calcified, that's when,
when you get cauliflower ear, I've
got a piece on my knuckle, ma'am.
I got this one knuckle,
it hurts like hell.
Every time I punch the bag it's
because I caught myself, my,
my knuckle and then I taped it up.
I wrapped it up but blood got underneath
it and it like calcified. Ouch.
And now I've got, it's
weird. It's just weird not,
I have like right on this knuckle on
his finger and whenever I hit the bag it
takes me like hertz, two rounds before
it stopped hurting after get numb it up.
So I just slap it in there until
he risk problems. Not Anymore.
I got um, some of that, uh,
prolotherapy on my wrist.
I used to have a big risk
problem with this dean. This, uh,
this right wrist are herded,
um,
kickboxing like 1989 and
it was bad to like 2002.
My fucked with me until
I got for prolotherapy.
I don't do anything for it, dude.
Prolotherapy is the shit I need to though.
So I get it on my neck and it worked.
Oh yeah.
Prolotherapy I did it for three
treatments and it works for reals.
Prolo is great. I'll show you the place.
Anything that got like tendon issues,
insurance covers, shoes. I don't believe
so. My neck was, my neck was a bunched up,
like really? How long ago was this
point where I got an x ray on it.
These are the injections with a though
we're talking about Germany. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. Shit. Oh, that's
what I'm looking for it. No, I'm good.
Yeah, on the, yeah, that's the
best. Yeah. Regena keen. So Shit,
I'm going tomorrow if you want
to go with me. Really? Yeah.
I'll tell you when we get off this
thing. Doing it for your neck. No, no.
I'm doing it for my knee and my shoulder.
I'm doing it.
Anytime something even bothers
me, just go in there and just go
in there and they just inject it.
I just take some blood and yeah, I've,
I've so far I've had my knee done.
If I had my thoracic spine done twice
and I had my cervical spine done once,
I'm just going to have him give me the
one [inaudible] out of me. They're like,
dude, swoop hook. And most people can't
afford it. You stop talking about it.
What's a Miracle Cure? It's still a
Miracle Cure. All right. Whatever it is,
the shit is fantastic. So what of they
do? What's the whole process? The process,
which I don't shit looking all sexy.
They take blood out of your body and then
they spin it in a centrifuge and heat
it up. And when you heat it up, it like
gives your blood of fever. And this is,
I'm obviously giving you a very
layman's version of what happens,
but your body creates this
anti-inflammatory response
to that heat and then
that's in the blood and it manifests
itself as this yellow serums and they
extract as yellow serum.
They inject it directly into
any area we have inflammation,
like if you have a knee inflammation. For
me, it was my back and my neck, my neck.
I had a bulging disc to completely fixed
it. Hey, I won't. The whole process,
it took a while for me. It
took several months. Um, the,
the injections you space out, I space
them out. I had a two weeks' worth,
but then within three, four weeks
afterwards, it started feeling,
it felt good right away,
but better over time as the anti
inflammation aspect of that blood serum.
Slowly but surely brought
down any injury that I had.
And then within like months, it
felt way better. It's, it's amazing.
I was having some problems with my
need. Boom. Shot it up. Perfect.
Kick the bag like a fucking werewolf.
Now does it,
does kicks have,
I've shown everybody I know those kicks
on Instagram hanging in there and almost
half a century, 47 as
ops. I'm very hard kicks
Joe proctor. Tell let's
get rid of that. Can Yeah,
me neither time I got out
of here by eight. Come on.
Just some little standup and got a
little stand up. Just show up. Well,
well this weekend it's West
Palm Improv but uh, um, sorry.
We knew there be three weeks at the
West Palm. I love it down. I love that.
Every fucking three. I love Florida
though. Fort Lauderdale, West Palm.
I don't you love Florida.
This is my favorite place to perform.
Probably Exact Canada.
They're wild. Yeah, I love it.
So the next fight is Rick story.
Motherfucker. Oh Shit. There you go.
See the story in for up next,
this little bad little
fucking Barboza and Dunham.
After that we got to remember guys,
it's 10 30 and it said he's a savage
is these mother fuckers look it up.
Give me the white trash
out the green shirt.
That guy with the green shutters young go.
Yeah.
Fuck
brings back channels it and Brock Lesnar.
Have you guys seen this one
white cat that keeps challenging these
black heavyweight boxers and his shit.
Talkers keeps getting you the
troll. Fuck beaten out of him. Yeah,
he's a total troll,
but he's willing to put the gloves
on and actually get in there.
He got box a little bit.
He runs away with a body shot.
Last year I got drunk who dropped out?
He got annihilated by this dude.
Just some champ. This guy's like, what?
A wilder and wilder and then there's
another guy who just did it recently.
I didn't know he didn't get
another guy did it.
It chased him out of the ring. The guy
ran out of the ring. He dropped him,
got him on the ground,
need him in the face and then beat him
down while I was on the ground till
everybody pulled him off him.
Yeah.
He kneed him in the face and
be funny or is he just being,
he's an insane person getting famous off
of it. I mean, we're talking about them.
Oh boy. He's in the same person. He's
not good. It's not a healthy guy.
Poor fucker.
Just trying to imagine him wanting Deontay
wilder to punch you to Jesus Christ.
If that guy hits fucking
hard. Who's filming it? He
just brings his blades. Doug,
you have to film this because most gyms
I know that he would get beat up too.
I don't think he's filming it. You think
he's filming? I thought it was. Wow.
There's no,
he has a homeboy filming it for sure
cause he cause then how's he getting the
footage and release it? Release it. All
this stuff. I didn't know he was Juliana.
I thought they were releasing it.
I don't think so.
I don't know cause otherwise why would
they keep it? You know what I'm saying?
Why would they release that?
Oh no,
because they just wanted to show everybody
this guy talks shit and then they
beat his ass.
I don't know if he's,
I don't know who was just
speculating right now.
I don't know who I'm just saying.
I think it's,
he gets a homeboy who's down to and was
like, Yo, I need you to record this. Hmm.
I got to say this is bad that
I really want to say this. No,
I really want to say I like fun.
Let's all go. He looks great.
Let's go see this man. Let's go see this
on a huge screen. I buy him as Hercules,
as me, as to why I think that they
need to Redo Conan the barbarian again.
That James Moma guy was awesome.
He's perfect.
He's the best cone and of all times,
far as the way he looks and we know from
the game of Thrones and he's fucking
awesome. If you give them
a good script, Ripley's.
Somebody reads really good and he was
fantastic in the game of Thrones and he
was the best cone and of all time.
I'm sorry Arnold. You ever seen that?
He was the most,
I've never seen it,
but Arnold's the best ever seen her in
person. That not true. Johnny's not true.
Yeah. I met him. Giant man. Shoot. I
met him at the UFC is big. Very big.
Big Samoan man. Very nice guy.
Hawaiian is he Hawaiian? Yeah,
but my point being all, see, look
at that. That's some rock shit.
He did some rock shit.
This ridiculous.
Sampson doesn't move like
that raises eyebrows.
But Mama was the perfect Kona, the
greatest Conan of all time. No doubt.
I didn't turn on Swartz.
Pales in comparison because
Schwartzenegger was really good,
but he was still Arnold and
he had the beautiful mussels.
I read every book on and book,
man. I mean come to by Crum.
Crime does not care who you are.
Cross use chrome. It was
still Arnold. You know,
he still had that Austrian accent. Like
why does he, why is his accent different?
What is will Chamberlain doing in there?
What does he do it without?
White Broad Kane.
Motherfucking Velasquez.
How was the,
how was con powerful Brown pride that
with Johnny Mo? Was it good or no? No,
it wasn't good.
It was decent.
It was decent up until about halfway in
and then the ending was diggity diggity
dog shit unfortunately.
Cause I wanted a love.
It kind of had a good moma guys.
Awesome.
I'm a huge fan of the original books.
The Robert E. Howard marks. Yeah,
I have all of those. I read all of
them, man. The playlists. Eight movies.
Haven't seen it yet. I haven't seen the
new one. The new one. It did really well.
We'll do AP for me if that's my
kind of movie though. But yeah,
that's why I would assume
you would like it. Scared me.
Want to watch them when there's not
as many people in the seats so I could
fucking spazzes out a little. It's a good,
it's a good movie though, as well. Done.
That's good. Cgi Sun. They
can do some shit these days.
They can do some shit.
I really can. You know,
that's why they had to remake Godzilla
even though they didn't even have a plot
there. Like fuck it. Look,
we can do what happens?
They fight this Japan shut up like the
fucking movie. But we have to have a plot.
I will get to that.
This is what I want gun Zilla do I want
him to open up another monster's face
and shit down his neck. What is
this money? Guardians of the galaxy.
Is this a comedy? It's
a marvel comics. Um,
series from raccoon. Haiti's. Yeah.
I supposed to take that seriously all
while they were 100% be that don't see
them. It was like right after star wars
when everybody was doing like these star
things, but that's a right
cope with guardians of the
galaxy. Oh, this fight son.
I can't wait this fight, son Matt
Brown and Brown, but he can't wait.
He's so tough. Is that San Jose?
Yes. So I'm going to be there.
That's on Fox.
On had brown is so rough.
This fight is going to
be fucking fantastic.
Can't wait for this fucking fight.
I got Lawler and I know you know me.
I never make pigs. If I was betting I
get Lawler. I think the styles clash.
You might be right. It just keeps
coming back. I don't know, man.
He just keeps coming. It might
be wrong too. I'll tell you what.
I watched that dude fight. Anybody
who wants a fight. Matt Brown. Yeah.
Both of them. Robbie Lawler too.
He's a psych. Go look at him. Go.
Oh Dad. Eyes do dad. Well, he's
calm as fuck when he gets in there,
man. I'll tell you what. When he
was fighting Jake Ellenberger.
I'd never seen a dude legitimately
smile because he was having a good time.
The way I've seen Robbie, it's hearsay.
It's a very bizarre psycho, real psycho.
He got taken down by Ellenberger and
he had his juicy smile on his face.
Like he wants to take me down
a beat and then he got back up.
Good Butterfly Guard, got back up to his
feet, just dropping bombs and be sick.
And Ellenberger came after him in the
third, the third. It was down in the car.
It's came after him. But man, Robbie
Lawler is a motherfucker right now.
Right now he is. Um, he's always been
great. Also the hardest hitter at one 70.
I think one of them, he's right
up there. But you gotta hurry.
Can't discount Hendricks. Can't discount
Woodley. You can't discount, uh,
Lombard Lombard can call rack for sure.
But if you looked at who has more
knockouts and all those guys,
you mentioned more fights too though, but
still more knockouts at a higher level.
Lumbar.
Do you know what did a lot of his fighting
at one 85 where I think he was just
out massed by a lot of people.
I think one 70 you're going to see
Lombard put some serious hurt on a lot of
bard is huge.
Lombard made me feel bad about myself.
He is Jack Super.
Jackie O is even more jacked than him.
Yo El Ramiro. Yup. You see Yoel
Romero and you go, okay, what am I?
Am I a little barn?
It's a cartoon and they trained together.
He's a hero. He's a superhero. I was
trailing me like shopping in the picture.
No, I'm cool man. That's right. Never
see me. My daughter has a waste.
It's only slightly smaller than Yoel.
Romero's and his potty blooms out
his greatest fucking triangle.
Like a, like a terra
Dac Dolan. He's crazy.
Only person is as ridiculous with is a
shape is a Phil Davis True Phil Davis
shoulders the most ridiculous with it.
Ridiculous.
Like Tommy Hearns style for a two o
five pounder. Yeah. Y'All Ramirez.
He's so freaking, he said, did they
give Phil a fight yet? I do not know.
I don't think so. I do not know. I don't
know. One of the good guys for sure.
Great Guy. Great Guy.
Great Guy. Really Nice Guy.
That rumble Johnson ferry was a tough
fight for him and he's doing that chuck
man, horrible match. It was also,
he's doing a lot of talking about
Jon Jones leading up to that fight,
like trying to hype up a Jon Jones
fight. If he wins people, if you do that,
here's the problem. And if
you do have to win, don't,
when people get really upset with you,
they sit and they have a reason
to point at you. Like you,
he was wasn't even paying attention.
John Jones, he looked past Phil.
Phil Davis look past him.
You can't look past rumble at two oh five.
He's fucking terrifying.
Uh, yes. I just think,
I think Phil Davis, uh, overall is
a better fighter. Just style wise.
There couldn't be a bigger
nightmare problem wise match up.
Then Anthony Rumble Johnson.
He might've been a better,
he might be a better fighter than
what Anthony Johnson used to be.
I don't know if he's a better
fighter than Anthony Johnson now.
Cause Anthony Johnson now it's something.
Sorry. He's really coming into his own.
If you watched the fight with
her lab scheme, you know,
he'd beat the fuck out of our loss. Gives
jobs round broke his jaw, dropped him.
He looks sensational here. Sure.
And that was at heavyweight.
We're talking about when you Saturday.
Yeah. Well he's a natural heavyweight.
Almost 70 tried. Yeah, but
now he's down at two oh five.
My point being that he's just
a month Straw. Straight months.
He's a month Stroh monster.
How about him over him verse
globally fight. I love that fight.
You're welcome Joseph.
[inaudible] he's got,
I told you he's going to have a hard time
with Algeria in Hungaria was going to
be a war. I think so too. But
who knows. It might not be,
you know that power at two oh five could
be who? Jerry and Mike clip him too, man.
Anything could happen. How Jira you
watch that fight? We, Rashad Evans,
the only thing to worry about who Jiro
is, he, uh, pulled out with a back injury.
He's been doing it for however.
That's what I'm saying.
When you hear a guy like
say he had a back injury,
like man back injuries are tricky.
Like Lundberg is going through
a herniated disc. Matt,
Matt Brown went through herniated disc.
Like when you start
going through those man,
a lot of those fucking come back coming
corona to retire because of it. Yep. Yep.
He's suffered from it the entire time. I
know like me, Shit Man Nisha, it sucks.
But you can get an ACL reconstructed
in a year later. You're good to go.
Once you're fucking spine starts
giving out in certain spots,
you do rehab, you strengthen it up. But
the problem with a lot of these guys is,
look,
I've had a chance to take,
obviously I'm older so I
don't recover as quickly,
but I've had a chance to take
a full year off of Jujitsu.
I want to train once in the last year,
only rolled once.
But during that time it did nothing
but strength and conditioning.
Nothing but kettlebells. Nothing but
like no yanking on my neck, no nothing.
So now like everything is healed up
strong and everything is really good,
but most guys were finding
don't have that opportunity man.
They're back in the gym a couple of
months later you're going to have to work
through some shit and you'll just get it.
Like I talked to Matt Serra,
Matt Serra fucked up his back before
he had a rematch with GSP. I go,
what did you do about your neck,
your back cause you fucked her
back up pretty bad. He's like, Bro,
I couldn't fucking move. He was talking
about holding onto his back is like he,
it was at,
at the end of training,
he was demonstrating a move and then
something just gave out and he was just an
insane extreme agony. So they
give him an epidural, you know,
an epidural just takes us,
it takes the pain away and you know,
x amount of months later he's
fighting GSP in Canada for the title.
You know when you started
having guys come back from them,
they come back from back injuries,
but you gotta be super careful.
You don't make that thing a chronic issue.
Careful spinal cord kind of.
I was reading about Benji Radek the other
day because I used to be a fan of my,
I still am fan of Benji radic you
fought in the IFL good fighter.
Straight towards good fighter and he had
an issue with his neck and a was so bad
that his pectoral muscle just
deflated down to the bone,
his triceps and his pack. It
was from nerve damage. Yup.
Just went down to the bone Chase's yeah.
You're managing that he says and so he
had an operation he had to get when that
happened. Come back though. Yeah, he came,
I don't know to what extent
where there was 100%,
but it's certain came back slightly
at least. Um, but when you have that,
you have a brief window when you start
getting like severe atrophy to anybody
out there.
This is really important because it
happened to a friend of mine recently. Um,
one of Eddie's black belts, he had
a neck issue, is Armand atrophied.
By the time he got to the doctor, the
doctor's like, you got to go into surgery.
You have to get that opened up.
Like you can't allow it to go this far.
I can fix it though. No, that's
what the doctor said. He's like,
he atrophied so much.
He's like,
the odds of this coming back 100%
are pretty small. He waited too long.
We waited like many months of it being
like completely atrophied where he's got
one arm, it's like bigger than the other
arm, you know, and the doctor's like,
your nerves are shut off.
And the problem is when there's longterm
impingement like that, the nerves die.
They die,
they don't come back and whatever you
do get back cause like really slow.
So for sure when take that surgery,
right. Well you gotta know,
you gotta take that surgery
to open up the, the um, the
area where the nerves are,
what they do is they go into your,
your like your column where the, uh,
the nerves are and the open it up
so that your nerves have more room.
So they're not impinged upon.
They usually, they call it,
I think they call it a disectomy.
They cut some of the disc away,
the impinging disk. What is
degenerative? Uh, what does that,
when I say yes, that's what
it is, is from impacts.
Your disc gets smaller and more
smoke because they're made of,
they're a spongy material. Yes. And
the way to combat that is first of all,
stretching and yoga are huge.
Spinal decompression is
another one that's really good.
Spinal decompression
is big, like a, those,
those things that people do or they
hang by their ankles. They were
really great.
And I was showing Brendan this one that
I do with a kettle bell where I hang off
the thing real quick. Joe.
Super Flexible. Crazy flexible.
Kind of weird. It's not weird. One
time we had a meeting and we were,
we're talking about doing a show together
and in front of these exactly as he
grabs both his ankles and pulls his
feet straight up, sitting on a couch.
Do you remember?
I don't know, style. I'd never
seen him. Literally I was like,
what the fuck is he doing? And everybody
kind of was like, oh that's pretty good.
I literally went,
took both his legs like the way a
porn check we'll do and just went.
And I was like,
I'm flexible on the guy who finally
there was like a pause and the guy goes,
how do you do that? He goes, I just
been doing martial arts my whole life.
My body grew around, it grew
up. I was like, all right,
well, good, good meeting. I don't
remember what the meeting was about.
Eric Tanenbaum and some other people
and it was about us too in a TV show.
Hopefully. Hopefully you
is this, how is the brand?
That was 19 probably 98 stories.
Throwing.
Sorry.
Heat stories of fucking brute.
She's a thick kid. Yeah, he's a
brute and he's team take down. Right?
And he's a training with a
Hendrix? I don't think so.
No, I don't think so. Oh No.
Ooh. Oh. Oh Shit.
He landed a hard left on my brush.
A little shaky.
Yeah. Yeah. The lab on his trunk. So
that's with Ben Henderson, the joke.
Crouch and Arizona. That's
a good spot. Great sweat.
I love John Crouch to man.
Big Fan.
Big Fan of Henderson to near. They're
producing some good fighters. Man.
I liked what they did with Alex because
Sarah's, you know, he lost to, um,
you're Ryan t right favor, but he
did a great job. It was a good fight.
Most my most my fight, he was in over
his head. But that's a learning fight,
you know.
I have favor.
Didn't even start in the WEC until he was
a year older than Chris Harris is now.
Yeah. Tough fight. But they matter.
Experience you. Ryan housing his son.
How old is your item?
36 I believe.
I want to say 35 36 how old is he?
You might be right.
I Know Mitch reone just turned
36 to his birthday was yesterday.
Shout out to Matt Mitrione.
[inaudible] Holla. He fought.
He fought me. That's fighting that Louis
cat now. Huh? You see that Josie fighting?
Oh, that big talking shit to each other.
Oh yeah. Matte for whatever reason,
when the crowd he stood up
and Derrick Lewis. Yeah.
Kept giving Derrick Lewis the
throat slash oh really? Yeah.
That's fools are fighting.
What do you think about that?
I think Matt destroys him.
Yeah.
He's gotta be minding his p's and q's in
the standing position. Mitre. Own. No.
Michio can karate. Oh yeah. A kiddie
play in the NFL for six years.
South Paul. He's king speed.
What? He's fast, dude. Watch that.
Kimbo slice fight.
Everybody needs to watch that fight.
If you forget what metric
and in front of him,
that inside leg kick from the, from the
right hand stance be fight southpaw.
He throws that snapping inside leg
kick and a nasty right hook. Boom.
I think Louis is, I think it's too
much for Louis right now. Well,
it's a big assignment, but I'll tell you
what man, Louis can bang. He hits hard,
heavy hand for sure.
The ground and pound,
his ferocious ferocious Rick
story working that arm triangle.
I'm trying to go. I'm trying to go. I'm
triangle. Oh yeah. Keep that head there.
Sign. Oh yeah. Nope. Lost the arm position
so hard.
Rick story can bang man.
I was so impressed with him taking all
those shots from Calvin gas slum and then
catching them with that right hand.
Cause Calvin was on fire in that fight
up until the point when Rick dropped him.
There's a guy who needs to get
his diet in order, Bro. Yeah.
That's one thing. UFC don't
mess with missing weight. Yeah.
Nothing drives me more nuts.
Well he missed it the last time and
before that he barely made it on the
undercard of the Hendricks fight. Barely
made this, that this the second time.
What do you,
what do you get?
Five and Calvin Gasland 20% 20% of your
purchase goes to your opponent if you
don't make the weight. Ooh, Rick Story.
Which yeah, beautiful use of the leg.
Keep his opponent down a stronger man.
He's very strongly at this guy.
He came in at 10th Planet One night.
Submit it everybody. Did he really? Yeah,
he was strangling dudes.
Strang putting an arm trials,
black belts and everybody just,
well I don't think there's any
black belts there at the time,
but you know, good guys. I don't
remember who it was. And he rolled with,
but I remember Eddie was
saying to this guy is true,
and this is before he fought, he was
to fighting in the UFC. Um, I want us,
and it was about four years ago, three,
he's probably walks in 200 pounds, right?
It's big boy. Big Boy
got an interesting style.
A lot of body punches go.
Remember is supposed to fight
Nate more cart and then Nate,
whatever didn't get cleared because of to
supplement issues, testosterone issues,
right?
So then they put in Charlie men and then
c story had all that hype before that
Charlie Brenneman goes in there
and beat them. Well, you know what?
That's a weird fight when it's the
day of the fight and they change your
opponent and you're the main fight of
the night and you've been preparing for,
this dude is a wicked striker and you
think you're going to be doing some
striking and then all of a sudden
Brennan man is going wrestling,
go piss in the fucking hanging on your
legs and you're just not prepared for
that. It's tough, man. Yeah. But then
what do you do if you're Rick story like,
Nah Man, I'm not taking, can't do
that. The OCC, we're going to be fired.
Send it up your pool pole son,
straight up fighting again.
What do we know?
Not only that,
if you're a guy like Rick story and
your favorite above Charlie Brenneman,
you're supposed to think you're going
to win that fight anyway. Right.
He just was not prepared for that style.
Which shows you how important game
planning is for specific fighters when it
comes to specific opponents.
You know,
he mean he's training for a guy like
mark [inaudible] and you better best
believe that back when he
was training for Marquardt,
everybody was scared of Marquardt.
Marquardt was a mother fucker then and
he was a motherfucker at one 85 even
though he lost a child son and he was
still throwing bombs from his back
throwing elbows and still still
dangerous to the very end knocked out.
He not the Martin Kampmann knocked
out Woodley and 70 at one seven yeah.
That was afterwards. Actually.
That was after all this true.
That was after you got to cut, cut to
strike. Force won the belt, knocked out.
Marvin camp man, he knocked out as
an absolute monster. He's a monster.
Knocked out Damien Maia with one
punch. Countered is like, yeah, boom.
We was just like doing a flying knee.
How tallies ladies and put them on his
back and pounded them three rounds. Yeah,
he, he's beaten some fucking
Wilson Govia beat. Beat him down.
Nate Mark Card at one 85 was a
motherfucker back at 85 feet just to Huna.
Huna.
I think the way this is too much man.
It's just the way cuts just too much
for Nate. I think Nate is just like,
no too hard. It's too, I
mean he did it with Woodley,
but man he fought at one 85 for so long
and he was really good at that way.
He's always going to have a
hard time with the wrestlers.
When you get it elite level wrestle like
a guy like Jay all that could put you
on your back. Yeah. That chail
fight. He just went in with
a horrible game plan. He,
he was,
he was doing something the entire camp
and then the day of a certain coach told
him to do something and there was this
flying knee and you need a land power
shots, so that's why he's getting taken
though. I wonder. I wonder if Cheo,
tell her what
I mean. He No. Have you
got popped with EPO?
I want to know how long you
been taking that stuff for him.
He'd probably tell you as a first time
I ever tried it ever was the funniest
thing. It was the day before and you'd
believe them. You talk to anybody. Dan,
you might be right, Doug.
I've never tried it before.
Somebody told me I had to try to try to
figure when's this going to be out of my
system? They said three weeks. I said,
I'm fine. So I took it. Here's my luck.
Don't ever cheat.
Where have you heard from him?
He's fighting to Metamorris or here's a
match. A minimum [inaudible] Jitsu match,
which he lost his job on Fox.
Man, that's so harsh to me. Well,
it doesn't mean he lost it forever. It
means you lost it for now. He's so bad.
He's so good. I would chill.
Should do is he had a book, right?
He does have a book, right? I don't know.
Didn't he put out a book before this
came out? Put Up, put on another one.
Just put on another one. Do it like
Lance Armstrong. Doug Armstrong. Yeah,
but tails different in that like he
never lied about it for long periods of
times that sued people for you know,
but it was kind of funny that he was
talking shit. I was talking about Lance,
but I'm sorry I didn't want to delay but
rich story work on that left arm by the
way. Portuguese look. He's got a good
Kimora man. He's got a good Kimora.
The dude's got a role. Give up the back.
Oh, beautiful. Transition to the mount.
Look how smooth that was, man. That
was like lightning mixed stories.
Just just too much for this guy.
It's just to Straub with some beautiful,
that amount was textbook
John Brown triangle triangle.
Here it is. Oh boy. Yeah. This
is what I was talking about.
This is what he has is really good.
He's, he's a beast at this. They'll left.
Arm's going to, yes. The
gift. Oh. Nicey Nice. Nice.
How boys should be rolling away from it.
That's a wrap. See these old rap to it.
That's a wrap. Beautiful. Great to
just to, yeah, that's what he has.
He's got a vicious arm triangle.
There's nothing poor about jail
southern men. He did what he did. He,
well he's a buddy. He's a
buddy. Everybody. I love that.
He did great things for the UFC,
but then he did bad things for the UFC.
So it net gated,
it's right down the fucking middle.
Good things for the UFC. But
they did more good than, than,
you know,
a lot of guys are doing the thought of
guys are doing and it's not just him keep
busting these people. Hey, I'm not a
fighter. It's gotta be fucking, you know,
I gotta ask you something. Yeah. They,
Herschel Walker was on the phone with, uh,
with Goldberg and Gold Berg
asked him what's tougher.
I haven't made training or
football training, you know,
actually I have a matrix.
Oh yeah. By far. And it's
so funny how you know,
and football, you got those. This
August is a motherfucking football.
Y'All five weeks we got as a motherfucker,
even now in the NFL, you can't do two,
two days in a row anymore.
No more. No. The new players,
they create it because they
said it's too much on the guys.
If you have a two a day, the next day is
either a light day or an off day. Yeah,
it's weird mark,
you know, all that toughness training
idea that people had in their head,
they're just overtrained down fuckers
say, yeah, sure. Just overtraining,
motherfuckers breaking joints,
fucking up backs messing up next.
A lot of the injuries
didn't have to take place.
It's amazing how even after I read the
book to punch the punches about when uh,
the guy punched Rudy,
Tom John of which and basketball and
1978 after that punch road teams,
you know a lot to play. No more than
two basketball road teams a week. Yeah,
little fish. They realized that
it was too much, too much sauce.
So one thing they stopped after that
punch was no more because they explained
the book. What people don't know was
in those days they flew commercial.
So he got a flight,
the late flight out and the early
flight that they can't have,
they can't import, you're not getting
sleep. So that's what they stopped.
So it's little things like
that doesn't make adjustments.
But in MMA, you know, going through
a training camp, people asked us,
well what if you know some frequent if
Vernon Davis who's just this freak tied
in for the 40 niners what if he decided
to do MMA? He's such a good athlete, man.
I'm telling you,
when you're going through an eight week
camp and you're doing two a days and
three days for eight weeks,
no one's signing up for that man.
No one like why don't, no, it's
a different type of bird. Yeah.
And the difference between getting hit
and not getting hit or so gigantic.
The difference between being an athlete
where you never get hit by anything.
And then being an athlete where another
man is beating your ass. Not only that,
and you're going to get
your ass beat and training.
Everyone's getting their ass beat.
Listen, if you're at a high level,
you're not going playing grab ass.
You know,
in Orange County at the beach
and Newport with some rich dudes,
you're looking for the baddest guys
in the world and you're saying,
I want you to try and
whip my ass every day.
This man card, bitch, you
ain't going anywhere and going,
what is this show you're doing?
What is your spot that's going to be that?
What time's it start?
Eight. Where is it at?
Eight 55 you're set is fine. Don't worry
about saying, where's your show at?
Fine. Alright, got down at that west side
comedy. You didn't even want to go there.
Don't go there. I have to downtown Jesus
Christ. Nothing at night. Santa Monica,
there's Vampires, Santa Monica.
No danger. Even if you leave now,
you're not gonna make it so forget
it. Stay here. Of course. Well,
it's not that you got an hour, right?
It was my watch. I got an hour. Oh,
you're straight. You'll take your
10 minutes to get there. Yeah,
I heard it's a bad crowd, bro. 15 minutes.
I heard it's rough over there to
her angry. See how we're doing.
It's a lot of bad audience
members. Shit. People are drunk.
Some hacks around right before you,
they're doing all your best bets. Cops,
some guys doing some shit
about always built to dance,
taking a shit. El Gato, he has the
guy seen it seven times, so he knows
that he knows the routine.
No, not the routine.
Oh, Brian Count is going to have
to abandon some of that material.
It's going to hurt him badly.
He loves it.
He loves it. He needs to retire. God Dove,
you'd kill me. Viewers got a few bits,
got a few bits and been around.
Yeah, they're good though.
Very good. I've seen it.
it's hard.
You know,
it's really hard if you don't put them
on a a CD or a DVD or something and you
still have them laying around,
but you never put them on anything,
that becomes a real problem.
You don't know what to do with them.
Like what am I going to do
with these fucking bets?
Yeah. Look at this transition,
man, they going to show this again.
I love this fucking transition.
The way he hit that,
um, that arm triangle,
all they're going showing the end of
it. Powerful, shitty man. And the truck,
the a, the transition between
him being in that, uh,
him trapping that arm and
then hopping across dude.
How good it Frankie Edgar look. Yeah,
he looked good. How bad to Bj look?
He didn't look at that. He's not happy.
Bj. He's not happy with a lot of things,
apparently was hard. Wait, cut.
Obviously, and Bj doesn't use, um,
ivs thinks ivs are cheating.
Do you have,
he thinks that cheating
gangster, he's hard. Tough.
It was too tough to default. You
know what I'm saying? Oh, he's like,
you want me to fight like Bob Sapp
and shit. He's legitimate. Fuck.
He was ready on the best time.
Sylvia, one of the best ever.
I interviewed him way back when he
was a lightweight champ and he would,
he said he would have fought Tim Sylvia.
We fought Leo Machida Franklin. Yeah.
He fought the, but knows the Odo fought
Franklin. Uh, but Bj Fogg the trail.
That's right. But um, he said, uh, I go,
he was when Tim Sylvia was the champ
and he was like a, yeah. You know,
I'd fight him. Hey, you know, you never
know what happened. He might fall down.
I get his back. Yo, your
batshit crazy. He's,
you never know what going to happen.
You know. He was serious though.
That's looking at it as Gabriel
Iglesias got a God damn movie.
Kapow only in movie theaters.
Son Gabriel blow the fuck up
strictly by word of mouth.
No TV show.
Just rushing and how far you could
get to see him on Chelsea. Yeah.
And chosen. How come? No
TV shows like that? Yeah.
He doesn't need it. I'm not showing up
anywhere before 12 he doesn't need it.
He's like, you're fucking crazy. He
was making before this movie shit,
he was making more on
the road than anybody.
You would hear about him doing like nine
shows, bro. And a killer murder in it.
If a murder last month he's
been flying into cities
just flying into the city.
So he took the home like he
usually takes the summer off.
Not this year for the last month,
he's just been flying into cities
going into that baddest radio station.
The same.
You motherfuckers want to do that and
then just setting up a show somewhere that
night and like crazy.
We got a comedy clubs going to promote
this smart man. He's a smart
man. He said, fuck mark.
Mr. Wheeler across America went to the
Puerto Rican day parade side of the float.
Wow. Damn. Killing it, Bryan County.
You sticking around. Fuck that shit.
There were no danger there. He told
us, they told you you don't know
what they say. Don't worry about
it. I know I can trust you.
I feel like I feel I can trust you guys.
I'm going to call Jason Tebow. He'll,
he'll take you five
minutes on a cover for you.
I told him there was a bunch of broads
done and Mike's excited. I was, I'm like,
you know, he's just
walking around like, yeah,
somebody was talking to some
shit to Mike favorite men.
And my favorite man punched him at the,
uh,
at the comedy store a couple of weeks ago.
And they were telling me about
the story. They say, yeah,
somebody was talking some shit to
one of these comedians and said,
go ahead and punch me. So the
guy punched him. I go, oh,
this is my favorite band that goes
probably Mike Faith, right guy.
Big Guy with like one of those old
school capsules. Paper Boi tax.
I mean that's Mike Feldman and then, and
then, yeah, what's Mike Ferry minimum.
And then I ran into Mike and he's
like, he was laughing. He was like,
you knew it was me. I go, yeah, of
course he fucking ape ape. He's crazy.
He's a funny dude, man. Good Cook. That's
right here, Mike. Favorite cookies,
barbecue,
his house.
All you gotta do is put on Facebook
having a barbecue man for you within one
hour and go look up. Here's
what we're gonna do. 10 pounds.
Don't do that. Just makes
you got 15 bitches. So
I want professional because
I want us to see resumes.
I want to make sure that
had chlamydia or something.
I want to make sure they go home
with disease and he will go you that.
You should go barbecue. I want to
be at, he will go three hours early.
Marinate the meat for you.
The whole fucking deal. He
really knows his shit. Yeah,
he really is.
Here's an interesting
tick. Edson Barboza only fight in the UFC
ever stopped. Two guys with leg kicks.
He really, Mike Lulo
and um, uh, Hefei aloe,
aloe vera by the way. That's
on my memory. Okay. Dot.
Kapow but uh, yeah, I can't think
of another guy who stopped to pee.
I might be wrong,
but I can't think of another
guy who stopped to different
people with leg kicks.
Mitre owned, didn't stop Kimbo with
leg kicks. Now he'd be in his house.
I mean the heart of this Kimbo
went like this, but not too,
but I'm just trying to think
of slavery to let cakes.
Barbosa was all leg kicks with Lulo,
Mike Lulo and then all leg kicks with
Hafi elbows or works with Mark Henry that
I was telling you about. He loves them.
Loves them. I was going down there. Yeah,
that Mark Henry.
Dude,
I was so impressed by your depiction
of what that guy does for you. Yeah,
make me want Jaeger made
me want you to move there.
I don't want to lose your buddy,
but I know go to jersey,
take care ass to move them up here. They
probably don't want to be there anyway.
Dell, come on. Brandon and
Jersey should be miserable.
But you'd be smacking people to gym
every day. He would have to. Yeah,
just people caught up.
Mood Jersey would,
it's all like you don't know my mentality,
you know there's a reason why
I'm not fighting in the UFC.
A lot of is my prior convictions.
They wouldn't let me in,
but if I got in the UFC,
bro,
you don't fucking memos that I
might not have like the best punch.
I might not have the bolt and the most
Jujitsu skills are something, but bro,
my mentality is I don't lose. I go,
fuck. I go fucking mental. I mentalities,
I don't lose.
My fucking family would kill me if I
lost and I'm going to press forward.
I'm gonna beat your ass.
And you're gonna feel that when
you're inside that cage with me.
When that door shuts, when that door
shuts, and you know my mentality,
you'll fucking comes out of me, bro. It
comes out of me. I'm like, I see red.
I don't even know who I am. By the time
it's over, I'll have fucking memory loss,
but you'll be dead dead.
People have memory loss.
I won't even remember what happened.
It's like a fucking became a monster.
That's his Jersey and Jersey
thinks he's something special.
I don't even eat, I don't really
just put me in a fucking cage.
Drove bottles and then Saturday right.
Became full glass case.
If I fuck cage up eight years ago upon
him and ask him on a Saturday and that
rezone, I went down there. Oh, those guys
didn't want to fucking wrestle with me.
The guys who tell stories
of the past or the worst,
the best of the best or the worst. I beat
Kevin Randleman five times the Yammer,
which is the amateur. What?
Amateur MMA before he came up.
That's the next UFC hidden camera
show is a fighter to sit with
the little camera right
here with the makeup on.
Like you just some old guy sitting
in the fucking audience. Yeah,
just going to the gym. No, you go to
the gym and you work out really badly.
Don't Bro.
I'm just going to go.
I'll just go on and Gold's gym the
other day I was doing dead lifts in the
middle of my set. This dude comes up to
me. I'm not going to describe big dude.
People figured out a huge dude. Headphones
on. He goes, bro, Bro, I haven't,
I don't know this guy at all.
Seen him maybe twice and then gold.
I'm only there out of camp,
Bro. Middlesex, Bro. Take my
hair but out. What's up man?
I don't lost you fight. Got To
get better. Got To get better.
You've got to go more aggressive
and your jab and he more jabs. Oh,
not making the middle of a middle. My
set, I need more. You know what I did and,
and uh,
I'm still sense of balance.
It's fight less than four weeks ago
I had to collect my thoughts on it.
How many fights do you have
man? He's all, well none.
I did some wrestling and then I'm
like cool. And I was like, thanks man.
Just put my headphones on.
I took every ounce,
not the snap his dick off every hour.
How many fights of just scrapping
and go good for you together.
That's a good question.
The fucking audience during the
fight and the real audience,
not in the UFC section. Oh, I've done
real well was coming up for sure.
And then you hear them look at
that fucking and they go, they show up
with that girlfriends all roided out.
Everyone's a blue bag was the amount of
tap out shirt with the sleeves cut off
and they sit down, hold on
to that girlfriend. And after
every fight they're like,
look at that guy.
He's that guy in the corner.
I fucked him up at that makes me
fuck that guy up at the tournament,
you know? You know what else is brutal?
I went to see glory kickboxing. Yeah.
Fantastic fights. Amazing. I
heard so much fun. Really Fun.
But when Joe Schilling is fighting,
you know his, yeah. One of his sayings,
he can't stop crazy. Yeah. So they're
all yelling. Can't stop crazy.
Like people in the audience can't stop
crazy in the middle of a fucking war with
one of the best Moy Thai fighters and
the way we want them knocking them out in
the fourth round was a draw after the
third round and they fought an additional
route and Schilling caught him with a
wicked right hook on the jaw in the,
in a squire old scramble. Boom. Flatlines
and for the first time, it's career.
First time the dude loss. Anyway, the
whole time can't stop crazy girls.
Guys, fucking everybody thought
like yelling out, can't stop crazy.
He's going to like, you know
what? You're right. You can't.
Oh fuck. It's crazy though,
is when you hear,
knock them out,
knock them out. And you're neglecting
the body. I just want to be like timeout,
bitch. I'm trying. I am trying.
What do you think I'm trying to do?
What do you hear when you're in there?
How has Barbara was nothing.
I don't hear any of it.
It's all just can hear my coach.
I listened to the other corner a lot
of the time but I can hear the corners
talking but you don't hear
the audience just to zone did.
You can hear boos and chairs for sure.
Dog.
Let me tell you about it when I said he
is, insurers didn't even let Ariana go
is not the only book. Buffalo like buffet.
You get that TV show now man, she's,
she's doing overall on right
dude. Dude, haven't done,
just cracked him with a right hook hook.
He landed a right hook and then exchange
what kind of TV show she's in. Overhaul.
Overhaul. What's Oval Hole? Overhauling
is a, my friend, my friend bud show.
Oh snap. There was a show where they
take cars, they stealing from people.
They fix him up and then they,
yeah,
she's had dumped just what is Donald's
background? I don't know ways of Jujitsu,
black belt,
ballet guy.
I don't think my probably dancing.
We danced against each other
in the nutcracker. Yeah,
he's got good fucking striking.
You hit Landon another right hook.
I'm the exchange after that kick dude.
Evan Dunham is no joke on the feet.
That's why I was surprised as
them saying that they have,
he has to take him down.
He's moving real good and he's training
a lot with Raci foe. Ray Is, uh,
done a lot of work with him.
Kickboxing. Oh, Don Landon and nice.
Right left hand there. That's why
I said that. It has been in the
tattoo chair. Get tatted
up. Yeah. He's got his, uh,
his back inside or done up
through the ribs or, yeah.
That's the most painful spot.
Po apparently
tagged them working on that single one.
One thing that Donna is,
he's fucking relentless.
Relentless.
Yeah.
He's been jogged a couple of
times to the Sean sherk fight.
I thought he won that fight. The good
fight. That was a real good fight.
So short and is done. Yeah. Um, yeah.
Sean's just had too many injuries. A
little, little too much. Tom Gas line.
What about the shy from Aka Fitch?
No, the other guy. Which one?
Koscheck. Yeah, Josh. He
moved right here. Ooh, Nice.
Needed thereby by balls on it.
You know Josh has been in the game for
a long time right now. I don't know.
I don't see him on be cards coming up.
Yeah,
well he lost a Robbie Lawler first
round knock out. This is the last fight.
I don't know if he's
got anything scheduled.
Donald was not like this crazy hot
streak and then they gave him a Melvin
Julliard. He knocked all that me
Gallard was on fire and that fight,
that was Prime Melvin Melvin's on point.
Super terrifying.
Melvin Gallard on point.
He's like one of the best.
It's one of the times coming
right in, man, look at this.
But Donald Cerrone Kinda
of his heart and he did.
That was a crazy fight in Denver. That's
right near an easy fight back and forth.
She didn't kick and then the right hand
behind it wobbled him with the Shin kick
and then boom, he shamed him in
the head off the left switch.
This is an interesting fight,
man,
but I gave done him way more credit than
whoever was doing the commentary with
the, with the stand up. He's pretty
slick. Yeah. You called it before.
He said one thing people
are talking about is, oh no,
load on the ball.
The ball's in the body and the
body and the body was it? Yeah.
It was hard to tell, but it looked
like he was it. It was his balls.
That was crazy.
Was he indicating that it was his balls
or was he indicating that he had hidden
and he got in the boat? They'll show
it again. They'll show it again.
I hope it was the bottom.
Do you want my Cheetos telling me if you
get kicked in the body like that where
you got to do fall into your back.
I'm getting your guard so
you recovery can grab them.
Most guys aren't just going to jump in
so it buys you time. Since he was a kid.
That's what he's learning to do more kick
related Kaos te calles mostly history.
How do you can't do my skin. It's
that interesting. Interesting.
I want to see the rings crew Pie.
Yeah, me too. Let's see this.
This is by the way, he was indicating,
oh no. Right in the solar plexus.
The solar plate, but it didn't look that
clean. Who it did? It's like a foot.
Look at this. Let's see it again. Yeah.
Grazed up right here. Right up top.
And the solar plate. We're grazing
with the toes, but gentlemen, I love,
I got to go. Oh, you savage.
You guys go to town. Go to
the funny, look at this man.
We all got in there, Huh? Yeah. It's
toes just dug into his solar plexus,
man.
I never thought about when he hit to
the body to just go to your button.
Recovering. Having him try and get in
your guard. At least bide your time. Yeah,
and he was telling me he kicked your
legs. Exactly. Which is cool. Yeah.
You're not going to fist fight.
Yeah.
You know who did that Veit tour
when he fought 'em fight John Jones.
That's right. So I kicked him in the
body. Yup. He went right to this.
One of the rare times you saw a front
leg side kick being utilized like that.
Like to the body. Yup. John
Jones. Man. Scary dude.
There's Mark Henry right
there. There he is. The man,
the myth when he gets trained
with them again, I don't know man.
It take some time. Go down there.
It's good time to be in New Jersey.
Look at powerful.
Gabriel Iglesias is blown the fuck up.
Who's the hottest comics right now? Him
and Kevin Hart. Yeah. Touch point. Oh No,
and he's a really good comment but
poshest because those guys are on another
level. Him and Kevin Hart's at the biggest
right now. Kevin Hart's number one,
killing it. Camp Williams is on
his way back. I'll tell you that.
I saw his new shit. He's so funny. Dot.
Williams knew shit is hilarious dude.
He had a new thing that somebody filmed
like on and put it up on Youtube.
I don't know if it's up anymore because
I think it was like his new special that
somebody filmed in the audience. It was
like a an audience. Youtube camera dude.
Kids on fire. He's back 100% and
I didn't like his last special.
I didn't think his last
special was like as focused.
I didn't think it was as
good as his previous shit the
rest of every fucking day.
How can you be focused? Dude?
It's funny. His own shit is funny.
Why was he getting arrested so much?
Getting crazy talking about drug.
Unless I'm drunk. I don't
know. He's getting crazy. Well,
you don't do that if you just eat
McDonald's. You know what, dude?
I don't think you could get a fucking
real comedian that's not at least
partially crazy.
Whenever I hear a funny guy
who's doing some crazy shit,
you hear about him doing something demons,
so if you're funny,
you had some demons.
I don't know if it's demons,
but impulsive comedians are nuts.
The ability to go up there and get into
a cage and Duke it out with some dude
did the average person,
they're not going to understand you.
So when you start telling crazy stories
then away they're not going to know who
is this fucking guy. The guy like me, I
embraced that and I said, it's so warm.
I'm like, yes. Like my friend
Tate, same way like Tate Tate,
Tate will tell you some crazy fucking
stories and he just want to give him a hug
and giggle with them for sure.
You know,
cause he's a savage and he
loves fellow savages. You know,
you run into a dude that is living
a life like yours. You know,
if you were some cat that's like a,
you know,
a doctor or a lawyer or tried to
keep it on the up and up all day,
they're not going to know
what the fuck to do with you.
Well a lot of comics at the
same way you do with that story,
a lot of comics are the same way because
a lot of comics are just maniacs.
I mean,
I keep it together as much as possible,
but I know a lot of comedians are just
maniacs and you hear about them doing
something crazy and you're
like, yeah, I saw that comment.
So when you hear about a guy like
Katt Williams is funny as fuck,
just getting arrested all over the place
and do a nutty shit and screaming and
audience. He like, yeah, he's
got a fucking hit it kind
of an engine in there, man.
Sometimes that fucker over heats sometimes
blows a rod. I think toughest thing,
maybe the same with comics is you guys
are on the road and you gotta be on,
there's so much stimulus all the time is
when I get home, I just, I have anxiety.
I can't like sit down and relax.
I Ha I have to make myself busy.
I have to have stuff going on really well.
I have a family,
so it's very different.
So when I get home,
I chill out and just hanging out with the
little ones and just have a good time.
I like to get in the pool and
really learn how to do that. Yeah,
I bet over the last few years of my life,
I've learned how to really,
really relaxed and just shut my phone off.
Don't answer any emails,
don't look at my, uh, you know, I don't
do anything. I don't read the news.
I don't do shit for hours at a time.
And if I don't do anything,
I feel like I'm slacking and being lazy.
Well,
there's certain times that I
definitely feel like that too.
There's definitely times
that I feel like that too,
but as long as I've covered all my basis,
as long as I get all my shit done,
but I can't enjoy a vacation. If I don't
get all my shit done, I found that, yep.
Then I'm, if I can't, if I haven't
gotten my shit down, it's just,
it eats at me again. Anxiety. Like
I went to King coon after that, uh,
Arlovski fight.
Literally all I could think about as
there lots of fight and how I'm going to
change. Strang yeah.
All I did your course,
you could have put me in
Nebraska and it had been exactly,
it wouldn't matter where I was. Beach was
great. I mean now that manner, the food,
I could care less about you just sticking
them out. The most important thing.
Yeah. It's no way around that man. If
you want to get great at something,
you have to have madness.
And the only way you're ever
really going to appreciate the, uh,
like a significant growth
moment in your life,
like a big loss where you just really
felt like shit. You got to feel that pain.
You got to feel that pain.
So it motivates the change.
She would feel that pain so that you,
you up your training crazy man.
He told him I have to,
are not a in nothing
and an Evan Dunham's uh,
defense or nothing's worse than
in hit there, man. It's true.
But Donald has talked to shit beast.
It's just so unusual. I agree.
I've seen him get lit up like that.
Wow.
It's crazy because that easily could
have been in any other fight. I mean,
I no doubt about it. It hurt
like fucking hell. I mean,
I haven't done them as tough as shit.
If he went down, he's, he's the reason.
There's a reason.
But in any other fight that,
but just been an exchange with nothing
happened in the fight. Kept going weird.
My bowser can crack though. That's what,
that's all about. Those as a beast. Yeah.
He kicks fucking hard on the 11 o'clock
in New Jersey and it's Wednesday night
leaving Wednesday night and
these savages is still out.
Most of them stuff to do it too. Oh Shit.
Rondo's girl who fight Ronda Jessamine.
Duda Solomon Duke. When the four
one more spin. More swimming.
I don't know what you call it. What is
that about when of course women. Well,
it's uh, just the men. The
other girl fights in the UFC.
Marina and Rhonda.
Who this chicken was good.
The chicken was part of the squad.
She's on the Rhonda Program. Yeah,
but there's another one. Her opponent. The
other one's a beast. Yeah. Rubies moves.
Good.
Yup.
I think she took down an eight days notice
to Frankie Edgar. He'd fight your Rye.
A favorite one 40. Ooh. I'd love to see
that fight. If the right situation arises.
He says, Holy Shit, be a great fight. Why
don't they just fight at one 45 I agree.
You're right.
Fought at one 45 before he could do it.
I agree for Frankie.
That's gotta be a hard ass cut another
five more pounds that they can do it.
Look a Mel Gibson hate Jews still
make a fucking movies that bad ass
motherfucker.
I guess this is the Stallone production.
You can do whatever the fuck he want.
They filming a boat Garrick cause you
don't have to pay the same eye as taxes
and you don't have to get like permits
to blow shit up so he doesn't bulk
Garrett cause cool dog blow up
whatever you want. Stay alone.
God alone.
There's never been a dude closer to 70
that's still kicking ass in a convincing
manner.
I agree.
He just jumped off a building
onto a helicopter and a
movie and he's 70 straight
up,
straight up,
jumped off of a fucking building
onto a helicopter 70 like this
with only one lip that moves
kinda chicken heads. He's dealing with
this alone. 50 year old chicken hats.
You've got to up your chicken head.
The number to age where you're
tolerated wasn't so I don't think,
I think you've spoken with 2124 year olds.
You don't take pictures of women.
Did you know that Smith is his wife?
I remember somebody was telling us he
probably doesn't want to take no women
cause you don't want to deal
with the drama man and a woman.
But no women's Arnold's
the same exact way.
Arms the same way too late on those. Me
and him took a picture and he goes, oh,
and he had his assistant getting,
I was like, oh this bitch.
They get this assistant in there
every time. Yeah. Every time. Die Eye.
It has to be for some reason because you
know chicken heads are going to keep it
and then post say, no, look at this. We
were here, then he raped me or whatever.
Bullshit. It certainly probably
can't happen. Boom. Bam,
Bop, Bop. So in the next
fight is Jessamyn. Yeah.
Jessamine Duke. I think that fight
already happens on it did. Yeah.
It already took place. So, so
Miller is the next fight. No,
they're going to put it
in Mac at the time. Yeah.
You're going to put it into a at time,
probably the earliest and shit. Oh No,
it did happen earlier. That's what I'm
saying. Yeah. But it probably ended early.
So be a fast fight them. Sorry.
Um, maybe, maybe not, you know,
first round stoppage.
And right now it's only
eight 1535 minutes.
I told you have 45 minutes is
probably a first round fight. Yeah.
Dan and I'll put the other one. There
you go. Nine o'clock. It's over.
Powerful women's Bantam weight.
Wipeout they know white still not making
a fuck of the parents in Atlantic city.
I told you he's up in his room,
but 18 fucking body God
called Kimbo slice back at
just a god out there that
Duke has got some long reach son. Oh
Shit. Good right hand by the other girl.
Okay.
Uh, adjustment only has I think, I think
your records. Three and one real quick.
Yeah. She lost her last fight. Yeah,
she's three in one I think
might be foreign one.
What did she fight my last fight?
Uh, she fought home girl who, uh,
threw up the for, what's her
name? Uh, has that weird name?
Brazilin Amanda Nunez?
No, I forget her name,
but a batch. Oh,
Pechakucha hair. Yup. Yeah.
Yeah. They were shocked that she lost that
fight, but I didn't think too, I agree.
I didn't think, I didn't think
it was shocking. Like they
were like, what the hell?
Like her whole corner was like, what?
Oh, I know. And I was like, come on.
Did you watch the fight? She didn't
do much. Just talented though.
Just got a good striking. I like
her length to, for chair super long.
She just has a user reach,
good front kick to the body.
It's got to be really hard
being a lot of these girls,
knowing that Rhonda is at
the top of the food chain.
Yeah.
It's just the level of athleticism
you're dealing with when you take it.
She's getting blasted.
She is just standing straight up.
One of these checks probably got
a picture around the whole wall.
She's drinking Roy eggs.
It's gotta be just like fucking rocky,
top down, just five rounds.
The doctor don't do remax.
Doe saw the most fucking paper view
mega come back by then.
Epo Free,
fucking free.
They'll give him somebody.
Hey, what are they going to
do? Speak of this. Okay, we're,
Brian was talking about this Guy Aubrey
de grey that he interviewed recently who
was a anti aging specialist.
If they do figure out
a way to reverse aging,
what the fuck would they do if all of a
sudden Randy coture looked like he was
30 years old again and he's
inside the octagon dope.
How weird would that, how we're all shit.
All my goodness.
The phone Cox fights over the time.
Rhonda on the bat phone.
I told you she looked good. Yeah, she
did look good. Did chicky dangerous son.
That shit ain't no.
Yeah, she can strike man.
She can still watch out. You
beat it any faster. You gonna
piss round off. Yeah, no.
Same. Then you got to find
it in your head, son. Well,
all you have to do is have a few of
those and you're going to have a fight on
your hand anyway. Oh, one more. And
the women's division. Number two,
you're if records three and oh, you're
in. You won. You won your fight.
You are now the number one contender won
my first UFC fight. Boom, boom. Yeah.
Very nice guy.
Look how she keeps her chin talk
this whole time. Her Chin is tough.
Oh Man.
Oh Shit.
Fuck. All right here. Look at that.
Left to the body. The right ball,
either shoulder and she
even adjusted the knee.
When she saw she was going down and
went to the shoulder. She's like,
she's not eating for a week now at
the Rhonda household. Lost you lost.
We don't sell all that damn bitch.
She ain't fucking around.
I got Puerto Rican chick from Amherst,
Massachusetts walking around Puerto Rican
chick from Larry Kelly's neighborhood.
Dave fucking around. Look,
El Nino shirt on. She's wow.
I'm telling you. Buff is the only one
they sent on this mission. She showed up.
I flew on the plane with
buffer from the stories.
That didn't happen. I have to
earbud with him. Otherwise,
we talked the entire 50 minutes nonstop
about girls. Oh no, he didn't go. Yeah,
don't tell me anymore. Don't tell me
anymore because I'll start crying.
Pavel, John, adequate
suite, purple tie on.
I hate how guys wear three piece
suits as Lee Smith throwing down.
Very impressed. Seven five. She's
tough, man. Super tough. Yeah. Yeah.
I don't like the three piece suit either.
They gave me a jacket.
I stopped wearing the jacket. I wore the
jacket for a little while, but I'm like,
what am I wearing this jacket to do?
I'm built like a bridge troll.
They don't really make track.
Well they do.
You look like you look like odd job from
James Bond. You don't want that. Yeah.
It looks very boxy. Cars to a man
with narrow shoulders like a Jon Anik.
More of a feminine gentlemen.
Beautiful Man.
Beautiful MEMFix skinny flooring to pull
off a suffix. He can pull off a suit.
I looked like an ape. I look like
someone trying to dress up a monkey.
I love me some soup. I just can't have
that extra clothing. I just got too much.
Not you either. He's on West
going, I feel like a loser. Loser.
Loser. I do. I'm not kidding.
I feel like some guys feel uncomfortable
suck in the man's Dick Sucking Dick for
the man.
When my fucking suit on hedging the three,
they could've started off in
something a little more subtle.
I can put you in a three piece.
I showed you a traditional,
I'm very traditional with my ties.
It's just pathetic. It's a
silly outfit. And not only that,
it's an Alpha that leaves
you vulnerable to attack.
I don't like having a fucking
handle around my neck. I'm sorry.
I've been kava choked and Kanga times
super uncomfortable in a Zeke yield.
Many a day.
I've been a,
I've been caught with
that fucking clock choke.
The guys get to come around and they
go like that and then go on to the arm.
That's nasty. That's a nasty chuck.
And that's all about your collar.
Why would you have a tie on if you've
got a tie on and it's a strong tie,
you're a dead man. You're
screwed. You're a dead man.
They weren't thinking about that because
everyone's, but he's worried about,
oh shit. Oh, it's coming next. If
you, if a guy has a tie on, okay.
And you slip your hand around that
not so it's not going to change.
So it's not going to slip in around
either controlling that knot and then you
start cranking. Yeah. And you get it.
Like you get side control
on this motherfucker and
you start cranking on that
night. He's a dead man. Yeah. That's
if you decide he's dead, he's dead.
You left a handle on if you do,
if,
if Billy from the nine to five
office does it there straight. Yeah.
Well that's true. But I'm saying
someone who's choke guys before,
someone who had any strong
person who understands the move,
it's not a complicated move
as he keeled chokes, you know,
anything like we collared,
Choking Column Two,
fingers snapping act.
But do you teach somebody,
you know this one where you
reach back with the hand,
like the karate chop and you grabbed the
back of the neck and then you do this
one right here through it.
God,
so much power in that you teach someone
that first day they kill somebody's
first day,
first day they got a submission.
Ah,
there's Brennan looking sexy as
fuck. No. Three piece suit. Note it.
Ladies and gentlemen, sir. Well,
I was UFC now. Yeah. No, I'll,
I'll rock a nice jacket. But three
piece. No. Yeah, UFC fight pass.
I'm a member bypass who's not a member.
I love the fact they're putting all this,
they're being proactive.
Put all these fights on
the Internet in the future.
That's going to be where
it's at, man. For sure.
You're going to have a fight pass app
that's going to be on your television or
just whatever and you're gonna be able
to watch TV, right? Apple TV, Netflix,
all that stuff. Yup. Yup. Powerful.
Brian. Stan. Little too handsome.
Little to big 10 next to Brian.
They look a little weird.
It looks like you want them in a,
yeah, like some sort of contest. Jon.
Anik has different hands. Donaldson.
Roni, Jim Miller, six and seven.
Oh Shit. Yeah. That's a beast of a
what? A division. What a division.
I hope Josh Thompson gets some good
fights in, you know, he's like 35 36 now.
Right?
The last one he's thinking about retiring.
I think it was just don't give
them that number four though.
Don't we give Thompson
number four beep hapy what?
Joe Don't give anybody
that guy. No, he, he,
he's also another guy where with
like who wants to find a beaver ones?
Like maybe next week. Oh, I got
something coming up. No you don't. Oh,
wants to throw down with the crazy qtip
what, when it comes out with that, uh,
the Russia crazy hat on. Yeah.
Shit. It's getting warm. Good Gary.
Good wrestling is no joke.
And he's aggressive as fuck.
Plus he comes from a place where death
is just a normal part of life. You know,
it's a very dangerous part
of Russia. Well they, they,
they showed him fricking choking
out of crazy beers and shit.
Four years old while I was playing
grab ass. Here we go, man. God Damn.
This is going to be a fun
fight. Yes. He was super fun.
I hope it goes a little while so
we can see the, see the game plans.
Hmm.
Donald has that tricky Jujitsu.
Yeah.
And then Jim Miller just has that
straight traditional bad ass black belt
Jujitsu. He fucking submitted
call Moise now that's big man.
Huge.
That's an arm bar from the guards.
The guards son come on as a boiler.
Gracie black belt, old school Jujitsu,
black belt, who's been around a while
for breach hill known for his Jujitsu.
So for him to be on top and for
the way he did it too is so slick.
Slip that Shin across the face
and then slap that bitch on.
Jim Miller's got a serious fucking guard.
Real technical guard.
I mean if,
if these two grappled,
if it was just a straight like metamorris
or something like that and worlds,
Jim Miller would, I think kinda
own Serone on the ground. I do.
I think you'd put a,
just cause he's positioning does a lot
more Jujitsu and a g no first Jujitsu.
Wow. However, in the UFC,
Donald has these couple of moves where
you just can't duplicate in practice and
by the time you,
you realize your comments too late,
how do you think his fight goes down?
Oh Man.
Uh, does it depend on which Donald Serone
shows up? Yeah, I mean, I mean, look,
we all know how talented Donald is
and sometimes more times than not,
he's shown up and you're in
trouble. Um, I, I think, uh,
Donald has a lot more
ways to finish this fight,
but I think it's the toughest fight
Donald's had in a long time. Wow.
I would agree with you with that.
I think it's a real close fight and
I think that Donald, when he's on,
and he's been on a lot lately,
he seems to me like a dude who's turned
the corner. I could realizes that,
you know what,
he might've had some,
some lapses in his career where
he didn't fight at his best.
Donald's also a guy who,
he's a wild,
when I talk about not bailing arrest
and not be able to turn it off,
you're talking about Donald who's
wrestling fricking Jaguars and shit and
jumping off mountains and driving
Harley Davidson's into walls and shit.
Like he's a whole nother level and now he,
Donald's not single anymore.
He has a fiance who's kind of calm them
down. So nice focus. More on fighting.
I think he's won every fight since, I
mean the dos Anjos fight. He lost he,
what does he, what is he coming
out too? What songs? Cowboy. No.
Yeah,
always CCR.
Okay.
She was a long cool woman
and a black dress. Yup.
Always CCR. They look at him. He looks
like he's ready to have some fun.
Yeah. How crazy it. He's
born in Sparta, New Jersey.
We Sparta high school. Sparta
high. That's hilarious though.
I mean you want to talk about a perfect
place for a fighter to be born. Sparta.
Both of you guys from New Jersey.
Yeah. Boring. Well, he's from Aruba.
You're from Cuba.
Yeah.
This is crazy, man. Such a
good fight. I love this fight.
Very excited. Can't believe it's about
to happen. This is the best feeling.
Not the best, but it's a
great feeling. You know,
like right before a big fight starts and
know it's going to go down. Woo. Boy.
There's some about being there.
Live to the kids are extra
little kick when you're like,
like cage side for Chris Weidman.
Leo Machida right before that Shit
went down, I was just goose bumpy.
My feet were like, my heels were
bobbing up and down. I was like,
Oh shit. You know, jumping my
knees up and down. I was like,
oh my goodness.
Here we go.
Especially a fight where you don't know
what the fuck is going to happen and
then like this one, like the Machita
Weidman, fine man. I was blown away.
Me Too. I've, I've never been so impressed
with a fighter with wide Nozick down.
He's the truth. He's an animal, straight
animals. The tank ran through everything,
but she did throughout them.
Machida staggered him in the fifth round.
He's still waving him on like, come on,
that's a on champ. He's an animal man
for his run is going to happen
while he's right now in his prime,
you know he's had his bass right now.
He's a tough guy to beat.
Super tough to beat for a long time.
Jock crazy. Could give them some issues.
I think he's going to do well
against v Turriff that is next.
I think vittores can have a
real problem with his hormones.
That's what I think too.
Yeah.
But if he doesn't, I think Luke
Rockhold can be a tough match. UPS One.
Luke Rockhold is a tough matchup for
everybody. He's tough for everybody.
He's the long, he's big. You know
he caught TRT RTV torn his prime.
When you mean caught, you mean
when he kicked desire? Yeah,
when Vito kicked him in the head flew
18 hours to Brazil and got kicked in the
face. Yes. Yeah. I mean
he caught TRT. Victor,
you don't want to be too or at
is very prime to go cal. Boy.
It's going to be interesting to see what
the differences is in his performance
now to tell him he can't take testosterone
anymore. I agree. Very interesting.
People don't think that's a big factor,
but you're applying day.
It's a totally different world. Taking
a playbook from paint man, and be like,
yeah, let's see how he does. Well.
It's like changing your body structure
and giving your body the thing that it
needs to recover the most. And this is a
bunch of, especially at his age though.
Yeah, exactly. His age and you know,
all those years of sparring
and screening and fighting,
here we go, baby. Ooh,
powerful city that don't give a fuck.
They all want this to be over.
So I go to white castle and get down.
That's what they are. They're really
throwing down tonight. That bus,
not the fucking ham isn't the
leftovers. It's over. After this,
these motherfuckers are fired up.
Isn't it funny that they put Vaseline
all over your face and then you grapple
and your head goes to guy's chest and
then your shoulders go to the guy's chest
and then you got Vaseline on your
shoulders covered and then you know you're
both a scrambled on the ground,
so his back and you're back and
everybody's covered in Vaseline. True.
I don't like how long cowboy shorter.
You remember the old days when they used
to let the corners put Vaseline on for
Phil?
Nurse do fill nurses rubbing it on
GSP chest and is in pretending like,
oh, we're doing voodoo on a
bitch. You put Vaseline on it.
You just put Vaseline on his face and
now you're coming up with some reason why
you need to do circles around his chest.
You're greasy ass hand
cause the he GSP was seeing this dude
who call himself the witch doctor and he
had all these weird things.
We'd line your shock where as you would
like they would rub the chest and touch
the back of your head and all this shit
work though the full, the undefeated,
it was
to the Voodoo killer.
Matt Serra said it was actually post
Matt Serra that he was doing all that.
I it makes sense.
Okay.
You got the guy's number,
let me know.
Well that's the one who's married
to his ex manager who's suing them.
All right. They used to call
her on board the witch doctor.
Powerful Dan Merkel, Yada Rock and
the gray beard like a gangster.
Oh boy.
Here we go.
Yeah.
This is going to be interesting
too because is from New Jersey.
Miller's from New Jersey cowboy's
a slow starter. Miller's not, yeah.
Crazy local power energy
coming towards Jim Miller,
the whole town of Sparta's in the house.
Everyone's [inaudible] New Jersey
was again helion. He leaves school.
That was a tough fight for
him. That's true. True.
But they fought so and then he went,
he went both bonuses then lost them to
piss pause for a marijuana positive for
marijuana. That was not a good fight
for Miller. No, that's right. Damn,
he's a two o $500 that's surprising.
Yeah.
Well maybe it's because of that Pat
Heeley fight like that was the last time
they saw him here in New Jersey.
That's true.
But Pat helion dawn's thrown it at
completely different fighters. No doubt.
No doubt. Yeah, completely different
styles. Completely different. Yeah.
Why do you think he wears those long
crazy shorts? He usually doesn't do that.
I don't know what he's doing there.
Slid up the sizes.
I'm going to have a hard time kicking
with them, but my only issue ever,
even if you get panelized,
you're still grabbing like the short
and take someone down and say, hey shot,
don't grab the shorts. Oh,
cool. I'm in full amount.
Thanks Bro. Yeah, no, exactly.
Exactly. Oh, it won't do it again.
It's like when someone grabs
a fence to avoid to take down,
that should immediately be a point off.
Immediately be a point of view, point off,
or you starting out or you're
like, no, we're such it.
You need something along those lines
because you can't just allow someone to
stop a take down and then they land
a big shot. By the way, Joe say, Oh,
don't Chad Mendez. Exactly what happened.
Yep. I'll do grabs the cage then boom.
Lens and needed the face of Mendez.
That fights can intense. Ooh,
they're talking a lot of shit.
He accused men does a pds. Right.
And then Mendez accused him of
ped backing out of the fight.
He said he backed out of the fight right
after random drug testing was announced
because he didn't want it.
Why do what you know happened to him
in the best mood whether we're going to
fight for it to get canceled. Who with
style fast. Yeah. Juice up the uh,
interest in it. Cowboy. He's
got that nice knee to the body.
It was just talking about that the nice
knee to the body does off that right leg.
Only problem is with a guy.
This,
he's going to time that knee
and take them down eventually.
Maybe that right is nasty though.
That needed the bodies is or hassle.
It makes you hesitate on all your shot.
Fucking hurts man.
And he did it again way again.
Big Left Doug. Oh good to the body
can just needs to get a sweat on and get,
he needs to be about two minutes and
he'll be straight early. He scares me.
Well he that early war with Barboza man,
that was fantastic.
That was my hit with the jab up
before that he was in trouble.
Well he was getting caught but he looked
okay. I mean obviously he was fine,
but Barboza really tried to take
it to him. Barboza who knows?
The knock on him jumps on him and
Barboza works with Henry. Right.
There's that needed to,
well you know,
they know he's going to know
to jump on him. Oh yeah,
so Miller's got him up
against the cage here.
Okay.
This is very interesting here. See? Oh,
all Matt sharp knees,
knees and elbows. Yeah,
in the clinch.
Very sharp.
Interesting though. The difference
between a guy like that. Oh there it is.
There it, it'd be careful down down
here though. Like I said, he's tricky.
He's trying to set up but try and
go right now until he has oh nice.
Donald Gamble. Beautiful scramble.
Damn. Very nice. Risk Control.
Straight. Threatened off the back and
then get that back up to his feet and the
transition.
Oh Nice. Nice. Nice trait. Right?
Another one
cowboy for wilder was in Denver. Just
wrestling all the time. Wrestling nonstop.
Who was you're wrestling with? Uh, uh,
leaster bowling or old wrestling coach.
She and Carmen and my wrestling coach,
I liked that he stops him with that
left knee just to create distance to put
space in between him and Miller.
It's very good at using his knees.
It both authentically and defensively.
He's like more authentic if
it seems with the right knee.
But that left knee very good defensively.
Ooh.
Hey, right up that left hand. He's
faking the takedown coming up top.
It could kick to the body by Miller.
This wrestling coach,
where does he coach out of um,
out a Mussel farm,
Jim legit wrestling. Cause loss of
farm. Jim Looks pretty bad ass man.
That's one of the places where
rampage trained back in the day,
right back in her day. And
now they lend it to the, the,
I guess you'd call them really the uh,
elevation team with leaser bowling.
It's like Nate more car, at least her
bowling. All those cans. Cody Donovan,
Brandon Thatch. And so that's where Donald
goes to work on his wrestling. Yeah.
Well he was a year in, uh, two
years ago. Last time I was there.
He was there every day.
Does Donald's stay in Albuquerque?
Who does he live in Colorado? Um, I think
you'd live and he has a place in both.
I want to say he has the
ranch in Albuquerque where
he has a bunch of people in
farms and you know, dogs and shit. Cats.
Damn Miller. Got To clench. Oh,
beautiful.
Take look at that.
He Card Wizard Roni back to the feed
knee to the body and the fucking clinch.
Nice.
This fight has put Joey Diaz to
sleep. No, no, no. That's a word.
What the fuck is going on? And this
is beautiful. That's a great fight.
I just want calvary, which he is. I
just want it to get to the second round.
We're going to see some shit.
He's doing very well in this fight.
Yeah. Miller struggling
with the, with the reach,
the reach and also in closing,
and Donald has so many
weapons and in the transition,
so get 'em down and
Donald's not staying there.
He's moving right away to help him control
him. Damn. She was well, she got to do,
has a nice exchange right
there. He's also, Donald's
been able to get right back.
Oh, nice. Uppercut. Donald's being able
to get up to his feet. Look at this.
Donald's crabbing with him minute to
go to halls trying to take him down.
This is nuts. The body lock. You
can try Gustin I'm pulling him off.
That's a windbreaker, right? If Donald
gets him to the ground, starts bashing.
I'm really is.
When you're not thinking about it,
you that you didn't think it was common.
Yup.
And he's so comfortable in the transitions
that he decides to try and take you
to the ground and constantly pressing
forward. Good. Good pressure.
By [inaudible].
Okay.
Oh, good. Right hand by Miller. Nice
short, right hook. Five people. Oh,
nice. Short right hook by
mail. I don't want this thing
to end early. We want this.
We want this going fourth, fifth
round. Yeah, please. I want to fight.
I don't have shit to do.
Let's take this to the fifth.
Oh Damn, that's right. I
forgot this was a five rounder.
This is sir. Oh Man. Donald
starting to get to him. Beautiful.
First round. If you weren't
around for cowboy. That's it. Yes.
I like how they keep the upper right
hand corner. They keep the fight on.
That's pretty cool. Dope. So you
still get your commercials in,
but I get to see if anybody
quits in between rounds or
something happens off the
point.
Do a part in the body.
Don't
rather this.
What's the matter of Johnny? What do
you want the Lord to help you about?
Turn this little fucking
fight has a tremendous round
tell you that great fight.
Yeah. That's kind of what I thought
was going to happen. Similar.
I knew that Millie was getting, getting a
lot of shots again, but I had a feeling,
don't worry, Bro. Patterns right
there. And we're here for you.
Do, did you do to Du
du, Du, Du, Du, Du, Du,
du Du du Du du down [inaudible]
did you, did you, did you
doubt? Oh yeah. There we go.
That knee again. Fucking
needed. The bodies nasty.
He throws that so well. It just makes you
fat. It fucks up your timing coming in.
Ooh, nice leg kick. Two on a
good street. Right behind it.
Okay.
Oh,
he's going up high.
Okay.
Again, with that knee. I like how he,
he drives forward with that knee
to good power in that right knee.
Donald's is starting
off this round strong.
Another strong need of the body.
Oh good. Right. Kicked by Miller.
Oh, front kick to the body. His
heart. He's heart. That's it. Oh Day.
Okay.
Well No, what? And Dan, he's saying it's a
grind shot. You saying it's a groin shot.
Wow. That all sounds shot. Body
Shot, son. Look at, see, let's see.
Let's see. Let's it, I thought it was
a front kick to the body. Uh, yeah,
it did clip the cup on the way up, but
it's the body that God, oh my goodness.
They're going to keep the fight going,
Yo,
that is in five minutes or did
he say let's do it right now? No,
because he doesn't look
recovered. Dang. Donald had that.
That'll mess with your mentality man.
When you think the fights over it.
You know what I'm saying? Man.
I think that was a friend.
Ooh, great body kick. Yeah,
he's just going to go straight
to the body. He knows he's
hurting now. Oh, Jim's.
Jim's forced to kind of wrestle, you
know, front background front kicks it.
Comments on. Dang that like
kicking him. Beautiful.
Sidestep to a confident Donald.
Good luck with that.
What's he's feeling it like he is right
now and he's going to start getting
creative. What? Wow. I'm Ooh,
another front kick to the body,
man. I'm not happy with that doubt.
That was a front kick to the body man and
mean kind of grazed the cup coming in.
But it was the body shot that he
went down to. Yes. That's crazy. Wow.
How do you play that though? Cause
Dan thinks it's uh, uh, growing shot.
I don't know. Can you do, you
can't let cowboy finish him off.
I think you have to watch the replay
and then he shows us a body shot.
You stop it. You know it's
over for Donald. That makes
sense. Yeah. If Donald Wins.
Yeah. Yeah. If the replace showed that
what we saw, I say the fight stopped.
I agree. Cause that he would, he went
through it again. Now he's hurt. Ooh.
Through a big right hand.
He went to him again.
Oh, he's just kidding. Hey, hey,
tomorrow's Jim Miller. Tough as shit.
Jim Miller might still win this fight,
son. He might still win this fight.
Towns keeping me in there and can happen.
Oh Man.
Dom was lighting him up with that job.
We could show up right now.
We'll look at his fucking Bon Jovi could
show up, but the whole bad right now.
And he's not even Bruce Springsteen
cage side could say that. Oh,
we tried to switch kick.
He's worried about that front.
The get down low. His hand is,
Donald's going to switch, kick him in
the face. I think. Well he just tried it.
Just try. But Miller uh, covered
it with his right shoulder. Ooh.
Nice leg kick by Miller.
I can't run into anything cause de Mille
and tried to catch it with that right
hand man. His whole body, his whole body
just tagged. His organs are fucking,
Donald's going to switch it up.
Oh,
but he's throwing a lot of kicks
to is I don't want this fight.
I don't want it to end, but it think,
I think it should have ended me too.
But now that's not, I want,
I want Calloway to win. Just
not yet. That's a crazy,
a bad ref call. Horrible call. Ooh.
I liked that inside leg
kick me town's doing work.
It's the only thing
that's working for Millie.
Oh.
Monjovi right now.
Right now he's hearing fucking
slippery when wet backwards shot.
Oh my God.
He's not good in New Jersey.
The band name the Brown.
Damn,
that was spectacular. Oh, did they
just said Joe. So the shake his hand.
He's back on the hunt for fucking, that
was spectacular. Well, you know what,
Joe Silva is on the ball.
I'm sure he thought that that
first one was a stoppage.
He should have stopped him.
That first one,
Donald was just complaining
about something.
I think you said it should have been
stopped out and stopped. He's right.
He's right. Look at this. Ooh.
Set it up with the punch
that the shit is perfect.
That is a perfect shin to
the head. That was, he looked
low and kicking. Look, he's,
he shielded it with the right hand.
Look at that blow.
That right hand was designed just to
stick out there and the Shin was coming
behind it the whole time.
Like as he was throwing that right hand,
he was already kicking.
Look, boom. See that?
That wasn't like right hand misses land.
The Shin,
the right hand was just a set up.
Just get a shot of yield to shield the
kick so he wouldn't see it completely
block the kick. He's throwing
it in the kicks right behind it.
He already knew he had fucked up too,
and he was mostly covering his body.
That was beautiful, man. That was
beautiful. God Damn, that was beautiful.
Damn sick. Donald Cerrone's a
motherfucker. The kid's on fire.
Just straight fire. So
good man. He's so good.
So good. This is the Donald Serone like
focus, like you were saying, you know,
got his shit together. Powerful
Joe Diaz. Where are you at tonight?
I'm fucking nowhere. I'm here
with you. I ain't got no gigs.
You want to come to the Improv? No, you're
taking half my spot. I want to watch you
do it for Joe. Yeah, I got it.
Yeah. I'm at the 10 o'clock show and I
got shorts on. I'm going to go home. Sure.
It's perfect.
I got to get up.
Gabriel Iglesias does this whole show
in shorts now. He's got a giant movie.
He's a good dude, right?
He's one of those dudes.
I don't know him real good, but everybody
is happy that he does well. Yeah.
You don't hear anybody say bad things.
Solid fucking dude. How old is he?
35 maybe 17 years.
That's 34 yeah. Let's
find out. I'll say, yeah,
34 maybe Gamebryo Brielle
you abl Iglesia yes.
Plus he's legit Mexican.
So the Mexicans are very excited.
You know,
they've got to look very bummed out with
men steal, yet they couldn't believe it.
yeah. Brian. Stan calling it
correct. Look at this. Boom.
The way he covers it with that right
hand hides it with that right hand me.
Those guys getting crazy good. I should
looking. Sure I beat him up that time.
I told you,
I told you right after high school that
fucking God that don't went to science
class wounds.
Damn.
Yeah. New Jersey is bad luck for you, Jim
Malone type these firefights Lord. Hey,
he's a tough guy.
He's only gonna get better.
Damn Bruce has on that three
piece talking to the three pieces.
Make them a comeback. Devil apparently.
Where is um, Miller training?
He's at his school, right in New Jersey.
Is that where he's training? Think so.
Does he do Mark Henry and all, does
he with him at all? Never. Nope,
but they're in the same town,
right? Are the same a part of those?
Where's mark hadn't Maria, he's in
New Jersey. He owns Pinos Pizza.
He owns a pizza place. Yeah. Peanuts.
Pizza. It's like the best pizza.
Where and what part of New Jersey?
Wow. I don't know what part,
I'm not familiar with those
two. The bridge. Are you
close to the tunnel now? Okay.
Can I was a kid the ways
out there was a peanuts.
Are you close to a WHO's a Jujitsu Guy
in New Jersey? Ricardo. Amanda. Yes.
Him and Ricardo are like best friends.
Okay. Yeah. Frankie, uh, Ricardo,
Frankie and Mark Henry on the squad and
they're like, that's the team there.
So Miller, his training in his own
place. Who gave me words? Black belt.
I'm not sure. Do you know
who he trains with? I don't.
I thought it was his school.
Right?
It was him and his brother
doing work together. It's so
important, Brendan. Sharp.
So important to be in the right
camp. Right? You're right.
That's what we were talking
to you about. Sun. True God.
That point and what I see,
you know what you gotta do a camp that
makes you happy and what these people
doing? Nothing like. I just read that
over marines with Greg. Jeff Jackson,
you know,
it's like Greg Jackson taking everybody
down there now the fucking save him a
camp over. It has been too many camps.
The fourth day you go, there you go.
Once you keep moving,
it's not the fight,
it's the fight or there's something
going on with the fighter.
You know somebodies Tom,
him some he don't think he wants to hear.
It's something he can't take.
There's something I don't like that
our camp is fucking really important.
You can't take your own boss.
No. It's like a camp for comedy.
You have your friends. You have three or
four friends that you throw shit around.
One of your friends will
tell you you're slipping.
That joke has been done before. That's
an old joke. You have your friend.
That is true. That's our camp.
Your camp is a home. Once you know,
when are you happiest? When your wife
is upset, when your wife is happy,
when are you fucking happy if you can.
You know what I'm saying?
It depends on what you're looking at.
Do Your House has to be happy. If you
had a fucking sign, some legal papers,
it's like finally she's mad at me. Let's
end this. If your house is on decisive,
you are going to be undecisive
and that fuck, that is true.
That's a great analogy. No, it's the
truth. It's true. It's true. You know,
confidence is,
is,
you know what I've found that lately
at the age of 50 is Jesus fucked.
And I wish somebody told me
at 26 is guess what guys?
Timing is everything. It's
everything. It's, it's, it's,
it's me doing the rights, scissor sweep
and Jujitsu to my joke, working Tim,
my punch working to me, uh, timing
and knee, you knowing the right time.
Jesus fucking Christ. Timing
is fucking everything. Yeah.
It really is remarkable in so many
ways that timing is, uh, is everything.
It's a lot. It's certainly a lot. I mean,
it's, it's about recognizing moments.
That's what's striking is all about
recognizing the correct moment, you know,
and the more you work on your technique,
the more you spar,
the more you get your timing down,
the more you know how to recognize
the correct moment. You know?
It's the thing with Jujitsu to
knowing the correct moment to move.
Knowing the correct moment for
transitions. It's a lot to everything.
Conversations.
How bad is it?
Having a conversation with someone who
doesn't know when to shut the fuck up or
just ends every story. Mm. Oh yeah.
Or every detail talks
over you while you're,
the worst is when you're telling a story
and instead of responding to your story
and talking about while that's crazy.
What were you thinking? What were you,
what's going on with you, Brenden? They
just start telling a story of their own.
It's completely unrelated.
Completely. And you're like, hey man,
will you not listening?
Like I just told you a crazy ass story.
You don't even have any chin's. It's
offensive. We're not talking here.
You're just using me as a fucking a wall.
The thrill rubber ball against, yeah,
yeah. Fuck yeah. Fuck, look, get it dog.
God Damn, he throws that
right. Neck kick. So good.
Perfect to look at it.
Subtle Blam Shin,
all Shin floppy foot,
right around the neck.
Damn credible fight.
Donald's run.
He's at his best of all time right now.
Right when you said don't want to fight
him. Yeah, he's on point right now.
He's doing so many things.
Well is the last time we lost Angeles?
Yeah it does. Angela, just a little bit
ago, like really close for this year.
He lost this year too. Yeah. Does and just
wrestled him. He was off
man. Yeah. Yeah. That was uh,
that was an interesting fight.
And then the Pettis fight
pet has caught him with that.
Look at these mother fuckers bringing
Chris Lidell back and Chris Lidell good
analyst. He knows his shit. Smart Guy
was actually running for office. Diana.
Smart motherfucker. All those
guys are smart up there. Yeah,
no doubt. No doubt. Kenny
Florian. I liked that Hanky.
Do you use it to blow your nose? Cause
I would blame you. That should be there.
Yeah. If I have a Hanky look, good. Call
me. I got a nice Hanky and their teeth,
you know,
I guarantee you this is some shit that
the UFC made for them like the UFC does
with me. Oh yeah, they got fitted.
They all got fitted for Syria.
That's why I have suits the UFC
hooked it up. I have an issue.
Look at powerful Chris Light,
although looking slick.
Good to see him getting some, uh, some
love up there cause he's a smart dude.
See this is where Randy really fucked
up taking that short money to go over to
that Bella Thor thing. He missed
out on this shit. All this stuff.
He could have been an
analyst on Fox for ever.
They would have loved to have him
on. It would've popped up. Randy.
Everyone loves Randy.
They would have pumped up every movie
he did to take that short money and go
over to that Bella tour show,
which was not gonna last man.
There's not enough guys.
It's just too hard.
Well who do you blame in that you
blame his manager, his friends.
I don't blame anybody because I
don't have enough information.
If I talked to Dana White,
I'm most certainly going to get a story
that's in favor of Randy fucking up.
If I talked to Randy, maybe he'll say
that. You know he had to take the money.
He needs it. I don't know
who the fuck knows. Yeah.
I'm not asking that idea though,
but it's a bad idea for a guy like Randy
as a sport is growing and all these
analysts positions. Who knows, man.
Maybe he doesn't like doing an analyst
positions too. That's also a possible,
I mean I think that's a possibility.
Of course. He's a movie star now. He's,
you know, he's like world
renowned. He could do seminars.
You can do whatever he wants. Maybe he
doesn't want to wear a monkey suit. True.
Maybe he'd be up there with his Bandana
on fucking weird bracelets and shit.
Hope eventually chill. Sones
backup. We're doing this stuff.
Do you think that's the best?
Do you think that they'll take them back?
I think they can take it back. I
think you'd have to. How do you do it?
The country forgives everything.
It's how he approaches it.
This is going to be how he approaches
this is all up to him. Well,
I'm sure the UFC wants them,
so I'm,
I'm sure at some point during an advise
them you need to do, you know, we need,
I don't know what you can advise though.
I think in Parkdale should die down.
Yeah. Part of the issue is what do
you say? What do you tell them to do?
It's all just speculation. Like what's
going to make it go away quicker.
I don't think there's any
time, time, time, time, but
it's not Michael Vick. Yeah,
but there's all they did. That's a
good point. Great. Michael Vick guys.
It's time and how you approach it.
I still haven't,
I still has a lot of people that hate him,
but I'm still saying how
nobody's Haiti on shale. Hey,
this was a,
this was very hard for Dana.
This is very hard for Fox.
It was just something that, you know, bro,
they wouldn't have let him go if
he didn't goof on people. Yeah.
People he goofed on people when sometimes
if you live by the motherfucking sword,
you die by the motherfucking shit.
Right in that regard.
I think they wouldn't let him go no
matter what goes on no matter what.
But you know, even the thing he
said about whatever gave him cancer,
he said a lot of fucked up things,
but he said he didn't say that.
A lot of shit was finally in a lot of
shit was if you would've said, well,
I would have said it, we would
have had props, man. You know,
he said a lot of fucked up shit and
uh, he knows this. He knows this.
What made him a star though to, you know,
live by the sword, die by the sword.
He became damn
this shit talker like late in his career.
Like he'd go to the early career. Oh,
like if all you see dog, macrame and Bodog
remember Brian, remember Bodog Yo. Yeah.
Motorboat on some good fucking fights,
man. Fuck. Bodog Day, really fun.
Bodog member. Uh, Matt
Lindland versus fader.
That might've been what brought Bodog
down through what they had to pay him like
$1 million to fight on the
Internet back when the Internet,
just like it was not smarter,
not there.
And then the homeboy Bodog ran the Bodog
betting website and that got shut down.
Well not only did it get shut down,
but he is like a criminal.
He can't even come into the country
anymore because he was operating what they
deem to be an illegal gambling site.
And so like Calvin Ayers was like,
he like had some thing with Dana white
where like he invited Dana said he would
pick them up on a private Jane,
a private jet and show him his lifestyle,
you know like cause it cause it you,
that Dana was jealous of him.
This is what yeah,
this is like when Bodog was like competing
with the u s trying to yeah, way, way,
way, way back in the day. And you know,
Dana was like, dude, you're a criminal.
You can't even come to this country. I'm
going to hang out with you. You criminal.
And then, and then did, and
then after Bodog went down,
then that's when affliction
opened up and sign fade away. Yes.
There was a billboard on Vegas.
I'll never forget it as I was driving
in Calvin I or presents and it was him
standing there like with a suit on. It was
like sunglasses on it, Shit. I was like,
what am I looking at?
I love it.
He's advertising fights by
showing pictures of him himself,
his ego so big and he's so fucking rude.
Well,
you know when you're a baller like that
and also he's also promoting a brand
right by by boat. He wants to
be Dana White. What do you want?
That's what he wants to do by putting
his face on the billboard and sort of a
back then Dana White wasn't even the Dana
white that you think of when you think
of him today.
You know today's a superstar.
Back then I don't believe he was nearly
as famous because MMA wasn't as famous.
More of the transitionary period before
I'm a exploded. I think it was pre,
I might be wrong,
but I'm wanting to say it was pre ultimate
fighter or close and then affliction
came along just paying or Lawsky
or Rothwell v Toward Lynn.
Lynn take through some money,
son. They have some main one.
Legit showing them their family. We're
broke. Here's the fucking man right there.
And one 55 no one kicks
like that, dude. Ooh,
whoo. Tell you what, don't sleep by miles.
Jury number eight there. Now he's good.
He'll be, man, I'm telling you the matchup
no one wants. Is that Habib cat? Yeah,
you're right. No one wants to
fight this beast. Horrible beings.
Just a bad match for everyone in the,
when you love to see him versus pedis.
Holt was shit. That'd be crazy. I would
really like to see what happens in that.
Me Too. You know, I get
criticized for this all the time,
but I'm gonna say it again. I think
that a guy like a, like a bad ass grin,
which everybody says, Oh, you
know, I don't like watching him.
I don't like watching and style. I want
to see him fight everybody. Really?
Because he's going to talk it up.
Just chill. Really? He is a child,
a young child zone and that's what he is.
Better, better wrestling. Better. Right.
But I'm saying in MMA that's what he's
kind of going for now. Yeah, maybe he,
well he's going for piping things up,
but my point is just to forget about
is talking. If he never said a word.
I want to see him fight everybody.
Oh, I want to see him fight Woodley.
I want to see him fight. Rory. I
want to see him fight Nick Diaz.
I want to see what we can do to him and,
and,
and you're cool with him
just taking them down and,
and winning by a decision if he can do
it. Yeah. If he can do it. You're cool.
We're on the same,
I'm just saying people are going
to say that's not fighting though.
So were you a fan of John Fitch? Yes. Yes.
I'm with you. Cause if you can't stop,
it's impressive. He's that good and
you can't stop it. It's a tactic.
And if you don't know how
to fight off your back,
if you can't attack off your back,
get back up to your feet or
stop him from taking ground.
It's super impressive cause you know,
hardest it.
Take some down and fuck
for 15 minutes or 25 yeah,
and I get it folks, you know entertaining.
If you say you don't like that, I can't.
I guess I'm a bigger fan than you. I
just like the real deal. Well, well,
the difference is is is,
is you know what's going on.
You have a history of mixed martial arts.
Those people just want to be entertained
when you get knocked out five times or
you win. You know what I'm saying? They
don't care how whoever gets knocked out,
that's all they want to see.
I think there's some mixed martial arts.
I'm being just completely facetious.
I think there's some legit mixed martial
arts fans that don't want to see that
ever and they were legit fans.
They want to see some action there.
They're the exception though.
But my,
my point of view is that I'm a purist
and as a purist I need to see, oh,
I need to see all the possibilities.
Yes.
Like we would've never known that leg
kicks existed if someone didn't come along
and start throwing them.
You know,
you didn't know that a guy could choke
guys out like hoists Gracie did until he
came along.
So when a guy like asking comes around
and he'd just take everybody now and he
don't show not like that.
I don't think so.
Not Fighting top top competition.
Exactly. Exactly. I know.
But look what he did to guys that are
really good over there. Look over where?
Over where Bella Tor.
Yeah,
but still still still whether you're
talking about sea level fighters,
I think B but yeah, some, some
deep. Sure. Some even a Chandler,
Eddie Alvarez. You're talking at a level,
right? They have some level for sure.
I'm not counting bell door.
I'm saying for the most part though,
Ben African isn't finding top
dogs so we don't know. Exactly.
So we got to see and the only one
way to see is to let them do it.
Jump in though. Johnny Hendricks.
Fuck yeah. With anybody.
Throw him in there with anybody. Really
good. You wouldn't want to see him.
And you know, name the
beast. Hector lumbar.
Jesus Louise's you're telling me you
wouldn't want to see Ben asking versus
Hector Lombard to former
champs from Bella tour? Hey,
how can I think if a guys, if a guys that
dom at one position, it's dope to see,
like everyone talks about the,
the super fight with George
Saint Pierre and Anderson Silva.
Hate to tell you that's not
going to be a fun fight,
Georgia than lay on if they ever
did fight, which isn't happening.
I'd say five for 25 minutes.
I just think GSP is laying on top.
I don't know if that
necessarily wouldn't happen.
I think that pride is a possibility of
George ever does decide to come back,
which who knows if he does and
Anderson is going to come back.
Anderson's already throwing kicks.
Yeah.
Have you seen that it a video of Anderson
punching the bag and he throws a kick
with that fucking leg slaps into
the bank. He goes, I don't know.
I think that fight does
happen and he'd get,
it's going to get market as biggest
fight ever in UFC history and everyone's
gonna be like, Damn Dog,
25 minute rest and clinic.
That's what I think you think so. Yup.
Be Interesting. Who knows? Who knows?
Who knows? But I don't want to see,
I want to see all styles. Dude,
I want to be too much.
For me,
it's very important to know what's
possible and there's only truly one way to
know what's possible is you got
to see those guys Duke it out.
You got to see the best guys Duke it out.
And when a guy is a champion of another
organization, like a belt or champion,
and he's been able to do
that to everybody over there,
and he starts talking to a bunch of shit,
but the random man,
the way the UFC works, so they're not
going to bring you in having a fight,
Johnny Hendricks,
then bringing them in and be like,
take number seven Hector lumbar. How Fun
was that? We want to get destroyed. Yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes. Yeah. I want
to just be dope. Yeah, I'm with Ya.
I want to see if he does and
I want to see if he doesn't,
if he can take lumbar down and molest
him for three rounds. Holy Shit.
That'd be wild to watch, man. Then we
got problems on wild to watch, man.
If you start, how old lasting
everybody's been? That's a good question.
I would say Ramona and wow.
I'm going to take 30 ass.
I'm going to say 31 let's see.
Ben asked,
just turned 30
30 years is plenty.
Plenty of time. A lot of turns
tomorrow. Plenty of time.
Plenty belt are wrapped up
in that contract though. So
who knows if we'll see it.
Yeah. What's up with that? Huh? Cause they
know well, no one's trying to be like, oh,
I want to build toward champ
for life while he's out though.
He's out of that contract. What is
it? The one fc now, right? Yeah.
Look at this to do a little demonstration.
Well, I see the socks. Candy,
sweet,
sexy red sox.
Yeah.
DC's just waiting for a shot. Right? He
had surgery, having surgery on his knee.
He doesn't know if he's going to have it.
He, um, he might not have the surgery,
he might just try to rehab it.
His ACL was only partially torn,
his MCL torn, so the MCL, he can
rest up and do therapy on it.
He's a,
you know,
it's 36 years old and he's concerned with
taking a full year off because that is
what is going to happen. And then jumping
in though Jon Jones Gethsemane. Yeah,
whoever wins. Yes. Or you know, who knows.
But by then if he gets surgery and
then the landscape changes in a year,
then maybe he's fighting Glover
or maybe it's fighting, you know,
who knows who he's fighting. He needs
to just wait for us title shot. Well,
it depends on how good his knee is though.
Because what if he waits for the title
shot and his knee is bunk and it goes out
in the first round and he could've just
waited an extra six months after that,
let somebody else fight and then
fought John with 100% I think.
No. As long as your foe, your
next fight for the title.
Once you're in line for the title, don't
do anything. Don't do surgery. Well, no,
I'm saying don't take any other fights.
Right? Like don't, don't get surgery.
Then they'd be like, all right, well we're
going to toss you glow over. Beat him.
Then we're going to give it to,
nope.
What do you think about
we're doing and cane. That's,
that's a tough match up for
cane. You think so? I really
do, man. Really? You know,
I'm always pro Jitsu. I just think for
doom, if you've ever seen that dude off.
See you have, he's huge. He's like
six, six. You know what I'm saying?
He's a big dude. Legit,
dangerous striking. Oh, and Kane,
he's gonna throw those elbows and uh,
that Cordelia teaching them all that
stuff and the knees and you want to take
them down off that.
Will the ball hit his fight starts
once his back hits the ground.
We're not talking about junior dos Santos
on the ground. Check Congo, a big foot.
No son.
We're talking about their very best
pure Brazilian Jujitsu artists and the
heavyweight division on his back
without a doubt. Without a doubt. And,
and also if I'm reduced corner
and I'm saying, all right son,
if he's doing what he did to judo,
Santos and he puts his forehead in your
chest and he's dirty boxing against the
cage, if that's going on
for a long amount of time,
you're jumping half guard mixed things up.
We're not going to stay in and get our
ass whooped. Like Junior dos Santos dead.
You're going to half guard. You look to
sweep, you're looking for submissions.
Very interesting. Very
interesting. I don't, I don't
know. I'm, I'm all about it.
I just, I believe in for, and this one,
could you imagine ever doing taps
him in Mexico? What? Oh, good Lord.
And then they find out we're doomed.
Speaks better English or better Spanish.
The same. You'd have the biggest
heavyweight stars since Brock Lesnar.
You think so? Yup. Why do you think that?
Why do you think it would be so big? Uh,
he has a personality. He's bilingual.
We're just going into Mexico.
He's a tough on a, he's a coach on
tough in Mexico. It very well spoken.
Good looking dude. Legit
legit skills. Listen,
Keynes is number one,
the world number one bad ass in the world,
but personality wise it's just not there.
You know what I'm saying?
And for doom as a personality match it.
Well,
you know the other thing about Cain
that he got to deal with is that cardio
cardio is off the chain
is no one like him.
Motherfucker doesn't get
tired or if he does get tired,
it is not like everybody else
can. It keeps going. It's crazy.
But if you've ever doom,
all right man, cool.
You're starting to get a little
tired and getting your ass what?
The first two rounds,
dirty boxing the cage.
We're taking us to the ground because
you're not going to sit there for five
minutes while you just wear your ass out.
Then we're in the fourth round.
You getting t code, you know what
I'm saying? That's very interesting.
That's very interesting.
It's weird. I could see,
you know like a crazy transition going
on on the ground where he's threatening
to you think of what he did to fade army
fado was trying that brutal ground and
pound that he uses on everybody.
Yeah, we're doing was like wrap it up,
snap, snap, snap,
snap and we're not talking about fate
or with the love handles like crazy
hanging over the muffin top. We're talking
about fiddle. Everyone was like, what?
See that's where I kind of disagree
with you because I think that fader was
already slightly on the slide slightly
but not big foot style where you're like
damn,
someone tossed in the towel.
We had knocked out Brett Rogers and that
fight before that looked great in that
fight,
but he was tested in that fight a little
bit with Rogers right hand and drop
tied hand and the reality of Brett Rogers
skill was at fate or shouldn't have
been tested by him, but no should
walk them. He's just not the same guy.
I don't believe that fade or is the
same guy is the fade or the [inaudible]
Fujita the fade or that fought cro cop,
the female or the fought
Nogueira is a different faith or,
cause I think he had been
through all the wars.
You've gotten divorced in America.
A lot of shit body changed his body.
He stopped being big and muscular.
If you look at those old fights
when he was doing strength training,
doing like weights and strength
conditioning training, he was way bigger,
way more physically imposing.
He was always,
he always had a little bit
of a gut always, but he
didn't give a fuck, you know,
but, but he was bigger than the
shoulders. Bigger than neck and the chest.
And then as he got older like it is,
he fought like Dan Henderson.
He lost a lot of that bulk cause true.
She's probably just didn't want to do
the weightlifting. Even even when, uh,
he fought for doom, he
was still scary dude, man.
Someone for doing pulled that off.
The difference between faders,
ground and pounding Keynes's canes.
Very calculated and very smart fade or
believed in it so much. He was just wild.
So that triangle is like snap son sort of.
But I really think that fader was gone
because then you see the fate or fight
with big foot.
Think about what Kane did the big foot
and then watch that fade or fight with
big foot and be like feta was never
really in that fight. It was a mess.
It was horrible. I thought they were
going to toss in the towel. Yeah. When?
When Kane was or when fader was on his
back and big foot mounted him. I was like,
oh, there's like two different, it looked
like three different weight classes.
He's not be able, Dan big foot's a
building man. You say months. Enormous.
Enormous guy when joint ma,
but speed if you can put chills
them. Yeah. If you can catch him,
that's how call me a lit them up.
That's how, that's how Cain got them.
Everybody gets him with speed.
You have to close the deal.
She going to do crack them. Yeah.
You have to. Yeah. Dumped home.
The holder in Brown Johnson who uh,
oh my goodness. That's going to be
fun. Here's that fucking crazy Combo,
Leslie Smith going look, cause I gotta get
Outta here. I gotta get Outta here too.
Let's get the fuck out of here.
They shut them at home.
Thank you once again for, uh,
another very fun fight companion.
I hope you enjoyed it as much as we did.
Please follow mad flavor.
That's Joey Coco motherfucking dos on
Twitter. That's mad flavor. M. E d.
F. L. A. V. O. R. And
then of course my dog,
big brown. Did you, did you get big brown
on Twitter? You should own that. I don't,
you should own that man. But uh,
Brendan shop on Twitter as well.
E N d. A. N. S. C. H.
A. U B. All right. Um,
I don't know when the next one of these
is, but a, if we're here, we'll do it.
We Love Ya. And uh, keep it together.
You fucking freaks Jesus Christ.
See you soon.